[Music]
it's finally here
the final in the opera euro rapid wesley
saw has seemed almost
unbeatable but magnus carlsen is eager
to finally win his first event in the
meltwater champions chester
so we are expecting an intense fight
between two of the brightest chess
players
in the world so we're very excited to
welcome you to the first day of finals
in the opera euro rapid
[Music]
for the second time in the melt water
champions chess tour we will see
a final between these two guys magnus
carlsen and
wesley so the american won the skilling
open after
tie breaks so we know the the norwegian
magnus carlsen is eager to fight back
and to safely guide us through this
final women's grandmaster ivanka
housecat and grandmaster david howell
and david do you think like in the
skilling open
we will have another tight race between
these two it's
almost too close to call kaya both of
them have been so impressive these are
the two best
speed chess players in the world right
now and i don't know magnus carson he's
going to be itching for revenge
he's going to be up against it though
against the super solid wesley so i have
to say david you're looking very sharp
today dressed for finals
exactly i've brought my a game i'm
hoping the players will too and ivanka
as well looking beautiful as always in
ivanka
this tournament it started with these
two players facing each other in the
preliminaries
right and wesley so won that game he did
that game started with a bang
with wesley so completely outclassing
magnus carlsen absolutely crushed him
it began with that game it's gonna
finish with that game but you know
we are a few games down the line and i'm
expecting magnus of course he's been on
a roller coaster ride i reckon he's
going to pull back
well magnus carlsen he barely made it
through from the quota finals after tie
breaks
he looked very solid on the first day of
the semi-finals
but on day two maximum vagiela gave him
a
very tough fight
oh whoa yeah it does look like magnus
castle he's just
i don't know if he's sacrificing or he's
blundering look at maxine's face he's
leaning forward
matt white can win a piece right now
whoa but look at magnus he was smiling
and then
his face and now he realizes he
blundered
and it's a laugh yeah look at his face
he just trapped his own bishop
his knight retreated taking away the
only escape square the only retreat
square for black's dark square bishop
maxine vascular with the last move
pushing a pawn forward black's bishop is
trapped
magnus is losing sorry
i can't believe this is happening again
magnus carson
he has resigned he's about to lose a
pawn as well peace and upon down
a huge blunder from the world champion
being 2-1 down in the match
carlson had to win game four magnus is
in big big trouble he missed that move
you saw his reaction
again he's missed another idea look at
black's queen
in the center of the ward attacking
white's bishop white's knight he just
walked into a pin himself
he self-pinned his own knight the white
knight can never move again because
the queen would be attacked behind it
magnus carson
that is definitely a mouse slip and it's
game over um well we're going to sit
right back wow
you just put his queen on a square it
could be taken in two different ways
magnus carson blundering and then mouth
slipping and
yeah we're straight to blitz carlson won
the first blitz game in the tie break
but he was not out of the woods yet bar
shoots up for maximum vaccine
and magnus is also left with 19 seconds
on the clock and it starts ticking again
it's going wrong now for magnus carlsen
checkmate is almost coming the black
king is kind of hiding out in the corner
it's trapped magnus carson look at he's
shaking his head he knows he's just got
to wait for his doom now
carlson lost and it was all down to
armageddon
look at that queen okay that queen could
not have been taken because the bishop
was pinned
white is actually almost ready to give
checkmate oh wow
magnus carlson's super happy he wins
i was just in a good mood today and even
even losing some some games didn't
particularly ruin that
so does that mean magnus that you really
feel the form is sort of
uh writing that that it is an uphill for
you now and that you're going to be in
great shape for the final
look i i i'm still making horrendous
blunders
well he certainly was in a good mood
yesterday magnus carlsen even if it was
a difficult day for him ivanka
but with being in a good mood there what
do you think that will do
with him before the final well he would
have been feeling
very very lucky because he scraped
through his quarterfinals against dubois
he also scraped through yesterday
against maxine vasily graf
his blunders haven't been too critical
and he's gotten away with it so i think
he'll be feeling quite euphoric
relieved and uh eager for revenge well
it has been
an intense fight for magnus carlsen
getting to the final he was the winner
of the preliminaries but
in quarterfinals he barely got through
beating daniel dubov in tie breaks
wesley so on the other hand was a clear
winner against young christophe duda
and wesley so was also very solid
against timora jabba winning 2-0
in matches magnus crossland as we know
barely made it through
um in thai breaks against mexican
vagielara but it is these two players
who will fight it out in the final and
david
how will it be decided who wins this so
the final will take place over two days
um a bit like all of the knockout stages
up to this point
um same clock times rapid chess 15
minutes per player gaining 10 seconds
after every move
if after these two days of matches we
can't separate them
blitzen armageddon chess more excitement
for us i have to say
it does seem like this format the
knockout format is what magnus has
struggled with has been great in the
round robin in the preliminaries
but wesley so is he a favorite in this
knockout format
it's gonna be hard to bet against wesley
so he's looked extremely
impressive very rarely in trouble he
takes his chances when they come
ruthless in his nature and he's gonna be
confident after such a good
track record in recent history against
magnus carson two great chess players to
great athletes
and that leads us into the quiz of today
ivanka
yes in homage to some of the videos that
will be coming up
we are asking everyone at home which
famous athlete would be the best chess
player you can tweet your answers using
the hashtag
chesschamps and one lucky winner will
win this may amazing prize and air
things device which measures measures
the air quality
in your room it's a fantastic price and
uh yeah once again which famous athlete
would be the
best chess player and we do know magnus
carlsen
we've said it so many times a great
chess player and he also
likes to keep in shape too to play
football or to go skiing
he does likes yes he does and
you can see on the picture there that he
indeed did go skiing
and unfortunately he did break the pole
so
whether this is a good or bad omen we'll
we will soon find out today
but uh yeah magnus taking preparation
well interesting approach
all right well he's up against uh wesley
so
today and is it a good thing david that
he actually has been out
you know keeping uh getting his energy
up today yeah for sure magnus
did scrape through yesterday but he
wasn't quite at his best and maybe just
that change in routine
getting fit getting some fresh air
that'll just get him in a great mood
for today's final all right the opponent
is
wesley so we have named him wesley solid
he seems
almost unbeatable he has played 28 games
now
in the opera euro rapid 12 of them
almost half of them
ending with victory so let's get to know
the style of this fantastic chess player
wesley so
[Music]
wesley has one of the most solid
strategic styles out there
in world chess he's extremely hard to
beat and he almost never blunders
he always has a harmony among his pieces
he knows where the pieces belong
and he always has a firm positional
basis
behind every move that being said
sometimes he can fall victim
to his own safety first approach against
the very top players in the world
he does occasionally struggle to beat
them this is one of wesley so's games
from the air things masters he was
playing white
against daniel dubov with the black
pieces
in this position white's rook is
extremely strong
eyeing up the black king indirectly
however the black queen is holding
everything together for black
it is the glue that keeps the defense
intact
therefore wesley so decided to sacrifice
his queen he played an incredible move
that wouldn't even have been on the
radar of many top ground masters
wesley so brought his queen in deep into
black's territory
this queen is actually sacrificed it's
undefended
black could capture this queen now but
then wesley so's idea
would reveal itself the queen the black
queen no longer protects the rook
like a take giving check and when the
black king moves
the final blow checkmate the black king
is now trapped
in it cannot capture the white rook
which is protected by the white bishop
it also cannot escape
as the other bishop covers its escape
route an incredible idea by wesley so it
shows that he can attack
when given the opportunity
[Music]
well he keeps having these incredible
ideas wesley saw or wesley solid
as we started calling him and why are we
calling him wesley solid david
it's simply because he's extremely hard
to beat wesley so
he's adaptable he somehow can suck the
life out of the position when he wants
to
as we saw in that last video clip when
he spots a chance when he gets that
opportunity
to shoot at goal he always seems to get
the win in the end and
um yeah he's going to be a tough cookie
to crack for max carson and ivanka
before the meltdown champions chess was
started we were talking about
hikaru nakamura being the big online
boss among the americans
but then wesley so just seems to be the
one person we keep talking about
what has happened to him in this this
online rapid format yeah he's been
incredibly impressive and you would
never have thought it
with the style that david was talking
about solid strategic hard to beat
because you would have thought it was
all about winning points but he has been
so impressive you know he's been
absolutely
wonderful and especially in his match
against rajabov
yesterday absolutely impressive even
timor rajable himself
actually tweeted his congratulations he
says good luck to wesley so and magnus
carlsen for the final match
we are going to fight for third place
with basharaf happy to be part of this
tour and not too good in semis but
wesley was
impressive and he also later tweeted
going to spend valentine's day evening
with bachelor
of magnus carlton and wesley so ever had
a dream like that
you know but that goes to show team
rajabov
himself is also incredibly solid also
incredibly
uh very difficult to beat but wesley
managed and he didn't even need to take
it to thai breaks
so wesley rising up another level
definitely and
talking about that david with the form
he's now showing in the online chat it's
a long time since we've seen him play
over the board should we expect him to
actually skyrocket on the ranking
on the rating list when they start
playing over the board again yeah i
would not be surprised at all to see
wesley so maybe challenge magnus carson
for the world title
in years to come he's had a great last
year um in
all these online tournaments um he won
the us championship
online and we do see he also won the
skilling open the first event of the
milwaukee champions chess tour
these are some of his achievements he's
got many many achievements we do see
his peak feed rating as well 28 24
it's the seventh highest rating in chess
history
out of everyone magnus carson of course
on top others include
gary kasparov uh wesley so also
two-time us champion and official random
world champion the reigning champion
having beaten magnus carlsen
he's done a lot of great stuff wesley so
especially in the meltwater champions
chester and especially
against magnus carlsen who will now face
in the final
i think we also have the head-to-head
score between these two players
in the meltwater champions chester david
and this is interesting
yes and we do see wesley so is ahead
with
five wins to magnus carson's three
wesley so of course winning that final
in the skilling open but also
in this tournament in the very first
round uh wesley so came out on top so
magnus carson he's going to try and make
commands he's going to try and seek
redemption
in their head-to-head score and we
mentioned it ivanka
it was uh wesley saw who won the first
game in this tournament and he was
against magnus carlsen
and we asked wesley about this yesterday
is he now actually
the favorite and he was very humble he
said no magnus crossland is always
the favorite but is that true isn't it
feels maybe that wesley so
is the favorite in this match now it
certainly feels like that so i think
wesley likes to portray himself as the
underdog you know
after all magnus is the big boss but you
know wesley has been
super impressive he really blunders he's
been smooth and his victories
he only had one or two mishaps and
absolutely impressive performance by
wesley
i do think he is the slight favorite
clocks taking down we are heading into
the play zone the final starts in
less than a minute and they're sitting
across the atlantic ocean from each
other wesley so
in minnesota he the time is 10 a.m in
the morning for him
magnus carlson 5 pm for the world
champion
and david they both have seemed to be
been very comfortable and very happy
with the time they're playing in yeah
definitely to
uh to very different players in terms of
their daily routine
wesley so he is a bit of a morning bird
he loves starting in the morning feeling
fresh
magnus carlsen i know him quite well and
he tends to wake up a bit later
and he somehow thrives in the evening
and we see four players ready we have to
remember there's also a fight for third
place here
and that is between maximum vaginal grav
and timor jabo
but of course we're gonna follow the
final between these two fantastic
players i think magnus's pitcher is
frozen there but he does have the white
pieces and ivanka what
should we expect from openings here i
mean yesterday with maxim vagelograv
a lot of the same openings at all the
time yeah these two players
will there be a lot of different
openings i think that they will vary the
same openings
i mean but we do have to remember in the
skilling open
that these two were like titans they
were slugging it out
magnus won then wesley also won i mean
it really wasn't
going to script the script is basically
wesley and magnus maneuvering carefully
they both have very solid strategic
styles and i was
i'm expecting it to be nuanced but you
never know
anything can happen and disconnection
can also happen i'm wondering if magnus
carlsen is
struggling with that now because i think
the first game should have started and
we do see his camera frozen there david
yeah that's right so magnus carlson may
be struggling with his connection right
now
um he will once he reconnects start the
game but that's maybe a worrying sign
for later on
it's always a bit tricky just
psychologically in these online games
knowing that
maybe you don't have the most stable
connection so we'll see if that affects
magnus carson later on
and apparently this is a frozen picture
from yesterday of magnus carlsen
he hasn't logged on yet oh and it was
supposed to start
one minute ago so where is the world
champion
he has to show up soon maybe he's still
skiing
maybe that broken pole made it difficult
for him to get back home and yeah
and we'll see if he arrives and this
there we have him
the world champion ready to fight it out
in the opera euro rapid final and there
we go david
that's right so the the final starts
with the queen's pawn pushing itself
forward
um magnus carlsen went for this strategy
a lot yesterday against maximum graph
trying to occupy the center
with white pawns we've seen an opening
called the nimzo indian defense
this is a very solid opening probably
the
the most solid opening with the black
pieces um
yeah it has a great reputation there
wesley so an expert
in this opening with both colors uh we
do see black's king is the first to get
to safety
and magnus carson playing a bit of a
rare move there bringing his queen out
to attack black's bishop
you normally don't want to get your
queen out too early she might get kicked
around
you normally want to castle your king
develop your pieces but there we see
magnus carlsen
um immediately challenging wesley so and
a couple of porn trades
um okay white's temporarily upper pawn
black can capture that pawn back
with his dark squared bishop right now
uh but wesley so reacting quite quickly
on that last move
to what i think would have been a
surprise from magnus carson
um it's definitely i mean it's clear to
me at this early stage magnus he's gonna
go for it in this game he wants to start
on a high and bringing out his queen
so early that what that has been the
success for him in quarter finals and
in the semifinal uh just trading off
those queens getting them off
getting into the end game and is that
what this is
intended to do bringing out the queens
early quite possibly yeah quite possibly
i mean
it was quite an interesting uh tactic
that he used against duboff he was
trying to
kill the game at the beginning against
against maximum battleground he was
swapping off queens and then expanding
with the pawns
um he's been very effective with his
strategy in day one
the only thing is that i don't think
that this is necessarily the correct
strategy to employ against wesley
because wesley as we know is super solid
has a very strategic style
so i think my prediction is that uh
magnus will be going for those
unbalanced positions yeah wesley's a
completely different kettle of fish
compared to dubov and vashi lagrav
if you give wesley an end game where yes
he might be a tiny bit worse
wesley's going to hold that draw more
often than not so magnus may be coming
up with a different strategy
um the queen the white queen did jump
out very early on but there's no
trade in the air quite yet black's
queen's still on her starting square
and meanwhile wesley so played maybe a
move that's surprising to some of you at
home
um putting the black knight on the edge
of the board but if we bring up the
analysis board we can see why magnus
carlsen is thinking right now
magnus was the one who chose this
opening but he's the one who surprised
himself um and after this last move
black bring the knight to the edge of
the board
black has an idea a very clear idea
later on once this bishop moves maybe it
will capture this night or maybe it will
retreat
black's idea for example um if we just
put a few moves on the board black's
idea might be to bring his knight
which has just moved on the last turn
capture this pawn and suddenly start to
kick around
this white queen the quiet queen having
to lose time and retreat
um this is why we often advise don't
bring a queen out too early um
she'll have to lose time later she'll
have to run around she's stronger than
any other piece so anytime she gets
attacked you'll have to move
and this is wesley's idea that's why
magnus carson is stopping he's
just trying to think okay what am i
going to do with this queen over the
next few moves
yeah i it's a very old line that um that
magnus has
chosen not so many games
but uh interesting that he himself is
the one that he's pausing
yeah um so magnus carson he took a bit
of a thing there but now he just brings
his bishop forward
breaking this pin along this diagonal so
black's bishop was doing a great job now
it's slightly less effective
wesley would love to capture this pawn
with his knight but first he has to deal
with this bishop
how will wesley so continue here it's
um definitely critical at this early
stage both sides
um taking a completely different
strategy here white with the quick
development with this queen
but temporarily with this extra pawn
yeah and now it's the bishop that
captures the pawn and
smile from wesley as he makes that move
yeah
good mood today the american and that's
always nice definitely i mean we are
still
very much following the games that have
been played in fact the earliest game in
this particular variation was played in
1948.
[Laughter]
and then it was played in 1950 and then
there was a pause
for about 40 years no one else touched
it wow
it's quite a rare yeah it's really
interesting that we actually have stats
for all of that and that it's actually
possible to see that yeah that's the
beautiful thing about chess i mean
pretty much every recorded game in
history
is available out there on a database and
um yeah that's how the top players study
i'm sure magnus he would have looked at
the games in positions
maybe not this exact position but at
least very similar to this um he's a
student of chess history magnus carson
if you show him a position more often
than not he'll say okay this was a game
uh between i don't know bother nikita
from 1961.
he i mean his memory is fantastic so
um yes he's thinking right now magnus
carson but i wouldn't be too surprised
if he
is quite uh if he's aware of uh games in
this position before but then actually
so we're talking about other sports
today as well
and especially football or soccer as
americans would say and
because of this that we have all these
games in the databases
is it easier to compare chess players
through generations saying that magnus
carlsen is the all-time best chess
player or bobby fischer is the all-time
best chess player whoever it is
uh because it's always difficult in for
example football
to say that messi or maradona is the
all-time best because
the stuff changed a lot in football and
the gear and the footballs change and
the pitches
change is it easier in chess i would say
it's not that easy actually to compare
players from before because you know
technology has improved we have access
to
information i mean you just compare it
to the times when kasparov and karpov
were playing
you know it was all about researching
and finding those novelties and just
actually
putting your mind and to work and
looking at a board with several other
grand masters
now you know i just turn on my phone i
can turn on my laptop and i already have
at my fingertips the power of a super
engine
so i mean it's totally different and the
information like
i can get what's happening over say in
india but there's a lot of great
tournaments
and chess players i can see what they're
playing instantly and the same goes with
online chess you know there's many many
databases where you can search for games
and just uh just kind of like chill and
just kind of
study these uh lines whereas before it
wasn't really possible and if he went
even back in time you know there was
certain
gentlemanly clerk codes like for
instance
people would sacrifice pieces you were
morally obliged to take those
sacrifice pieces they had a lot long
long they had a lot longer time to think
uh we're talking about like 10 12 hour
games
i mean it was and you also have the
system of a germans
where the game got too long you could
suddenly put a halt to the proceedings
and go
hang on a second i want my dinner yeah
let's uh
call it quits and i'm going to go and
study the game with my friends
so um it's difficult to compare actually
i think
yeah and it's not just players who have
changed over the years it's also
chess has changed the format of chess
has changed in the past you would see
world champions
um i mean there were no rapid or blitz
tournaments um they would purely play
classical chess each game would last
seven eight hours minimum and um
and yeah often the world champions they
would play maybe 50 games
maximum 100 games per year now we see
magnus carlsen
alone in this tournament he's going to
play what 30 40 games
um in total so um there's different
demands on the players they have to
adapt accordingly and
yes the chess might not be so accurate
we do see a blunder here or there but
it's also much more creative now because
we do realize that
chess is so vast and we have these
resources that ivanka mentioned um
yeah it's just fascinating to see um
just how that has affected the top
players and
yeah it's interesting to see as well
playing through those old games
how much chess has changed yeah i think
one of the funniest
articles i read when i was a kid was uh
how to play like morphy's opponents
it was like no no no no you play you
suggest that move that's way too logical
no he did not play that at all um yeah
very
very good magazine from kingpin
all right we do have a move by magnus he
was uh thinking for a long time
so magnus he's playing a move that would
not be approved by some of his
predecessors
potentially um if we bring up the
analysis board we can see white's last
couple of moves um we left it in this
position we were saying okay white just
brought his bishop forward
um he's moved his bishop once black
recaptured a porn and now magnus
moving the same piece again moving his
bishop for the second time in a row
we always say to those starting out the
game don't move the same piece twice in
the opening
you need to use all of your pieces you
need to especially get your king to
safety first
but magnus trying to prove that this is
an exception to the rule he'd moved his
bishop forward once
moved it forward again yes he's creating
this pin against the knight the knight
cannot move because black's queen would
be attacked
but now magnus has lost a bit of time
and wesley so playing
a very logical move pushing his pawn
he's going to develop his bishop
to this square along a crucial diagonal
this bishop is going to have a huge
amount of influence
um it does look like wesley so he's
going to be very happy with how the
opening has gone
meanwhile magnus carlsen putting his
queen in the middle of not square moving
his bishop twice
he now will face the pressure of how to
get the white king to safety
it needs to get safety soon otherwise
magnus will live to regret
his opening choices ah all right we do
actually in the skilling open i i
checked the stats from from the final
between these two that was very
interesting they
both won their white games on the first
day so
all the four games was decided with a
winner
magnus winning his two white games
wesley winning his two white games and
on day two
they kept that stat so magnus won his
first white game
wesley won his first white game and then
they played two draws yes
was very interesting that you mentioned
stats because i
have some also quite fascinating stats
um they've been provided by mr dodgy on
twitter who says
wesley blunders once per year
supported by multiple cats excellent air
quality i'm just waiting for the tweet
to come up
yeah and then there's also some stats on
magnus
yeah there's also some stats on magnus
which was like blunders once per half
game
no cats have shown public support poor
humidity
so uh i i quite like those that's
uh you know it seems to be in wesley's
favor that's right
it seems to be the favorite here i i do
like i do like the
no cats have shown magnus public support
so uh maybe some cats on twitter can get
out there and
start cheering yeah start cheering for
magnus he needs his cat support okay we
do have
two moves uh david then the bar just
yeah switch this up a little bit
yeah but the computer does think that
white's position has improved a bit over
the last few moves
i'm frankly i'm shocked by wesley's last
move which he's played very quickly
wesley so
maybe he's trying to put the world
champion under time pressure
as we saw vashta degraff do that quite
successfully against magnus just play
quickly
try to make him a bit nervous but wesley
so he's gone for the exact same strategy
that i said was maybe a bit dubious
um he has just moved his dark squared
bishop again black's dark squared bishop
it's moved four times now in the opening
it brought itself out
on the first move it went back it's
moved again um yeah he
neither side really respecting those
traditional
conventions of uh moving the same piece
just once
in the opening wesley so he's created a
pin um
with his last move against white's
knight but i expect to see okay
magnus says that dark squared bishop uh
yeah i'm also shocked by that movement
um he's saying okay your dart squad
bishop are you going to trade
or are you just going to retreat again
and wesley so has to move that bishop
who's just been attacked by a pawn
um i think the computer may be getting a
bit over excited there i think from a
human point of view yep there we go
from a human point of view that's a very
logical move by white but now we're
seeing trades
a lot of trades happening that was
almost blink and you missed it action
um bishop traded itself for a night and
suddenly the queens have come off the
board
wesley so spotting a very nice idea to
get those queens off
and uh currently we see level material
on the board white has a bishop for
black's knight
but lots of attacks going on black's
rook was attacked it moves to attack the
white bishop once bishop retreats
black's knight is now attacked in the
white half of the board that night i
expect to either capture a bishop
or retreat um two very logical moves
here for wesley so and
queen's off the board magnus carson will
be happy then again wesley so still with
a super solid position right now
no real weaknesses yeah somehow
i i don't like it i don't like it for
wesley
i mean it just seems to be playing
straight into magnus's strengths
you know we've seen wesley been
incredibly
amazing at defending his positions but
uh i'm
i am slightly concerned about this uh
there is like there's one pawn that i'm
thinking could potentially be a target
at the right minute which is the one
which is standing behind the white
bishop
that is on the dark squares i'm a little
bit worried that
maybe that could be something that the
rooks can pile up and every single piece
can
create some problems but okay we're
going to see some trades and
wesley says yes i might potentially have
a weakness but then you know
you also have a potential weakness
because there's a half open line for
those rooks to work their magic down
yes and uh logical blade by both sides
over the last couple of moves
if we bring up the analysis board we can
show which pawns might
be weak right now everything's balanced
same level
same material both sides have rooks and
knight and bishop each
um wesley so's last move bringing the
rook across attacking this pawn
which was undefended that's why magnus
carson had to shift his rook across
to defend this pawn it stands on a light
square so it might become a target later
on for black's bishop as well
meanwhile though white's hope as ivanka
mentioned is that this pawn
it's a backward pawn it can never move
now it's perfectly blockaded by this
bishop
and white has an easy plan he'll bring
his rook across move the bishop and try
and attack this pawn behind it
um meanwhile wesley so bringing his
night out
offering a trade would you take this
night jovanka would i take that night
um not for the time
not for the time being unless that night
is causing some
mischief let's have a look is that night
going to go anywhere though
jump in somewhere jump in yeah exactly
suddenly i i see it
no i'm not going to take it okay i'm
going to leave my bishop on the board
so when in doubt i guess improve a piece
right exactly that was what i was
thinking just to align that rook to an
open line
and uh i must admit i get a certain
satisfaction when uh
magnus or wesley played the movie i
suggest yeah he played that move the
same time i made it on the analysis
board and white's wrote now
on a fantastic open line um there's
actually a huge threat in the position
why it's threatening to play
bishop takes knight for example black
just plays a kind of innocent move here
um we'll play bishop takes night and
suddenly white's rook enters the
position wins a pawn
and also we call this seventh heaven
when the rook is on the seventh rank
he's got so many targets across this
line
um but okay we see wesley so avoid that
he brings his knight to the middle of
the board
really really tense right now um maybe
eyeing up this bishop but
uh it's going to come down to whose pawn
is weaker is this white pawn weaker
it can be targeted by black's bishop or
is this platform weaker
this backward pawn which is pretty much
paralyzed right now and
completely blocked um still in the
balance and it could go either way but
magnus carson remember a bit of an
endgame expert
um he's fantastic at these nuances as
well you know
the game looks very harmless looks
completely level but actually isn't when
you kind of like
it's all about those two porn weaknesses
and these two
half open lines and uh it's very
very tense at the minute yeah i think
magnus he'll be
happy in the fact that um okay he's
slightly below on the clock but the
queens are off it makes it
more simple in terms of there's no
immediate calculation that really needs
to be done
you don't have to look for long forcing
variations like magnus has just done
there pushing a pawn at the corner of
the board
he's slowly gaining space slowly
improving his position
he did this against maxine vasily grav
just slowly push his pawns and uh
suffocate the opponent and magnus
meanwhile just trying to stifle a laugh
there or a smile
but he's back to his game face and i
like that last move for white just
kind of clamping down on that left side
of the board stopping the opponent
pushing forward with their pawns
yes it's uh we call kind of call this in
chassis either the python strategy or
the boa constrictor method you know
you simply just squeeze the oxygen from
your opponent's position until they just
can't breathe
it's very unpleasant to watch so okay
wesley has advanced one of his pawns on
the right side
the king side we call it in jess and
i'm guessing that he also wants to take
some space and perhaps come in
and dislodge that really pesky bishop
yep um black's king now um maybe
okay nice and safe tucked away on that
right side but um the black king wants
to join the action
and that last move by wesley so it's a
dual purpose move he's pushed his pawn
forward
maybe taking away some access squares
for the white knight but also creating a
path for the black king
later after more trades to bring itself
towards the center
um kings love to be centralized once the
queens have left the board white's king
doing a great job
later on you can imagine if the rooks
disappear if the knights disappear the
king can dart
either side of the board very quickly
and blacks oh well
after magnus cast's last move very solid
move i expect to see black's king
now maybe reposition itself closer to
the middle of the board
um a lot of choice a lot of choice here
from wesley so
no right or wrong answers there's it's
all about maneuvering right now that's
why
we see him look away he knows there's no
real calculation to be done
he doesn't need to look far in advance
he just needs to improve his pawn
structure and improve his pieces
i do wonder where he's looking at though
and he's leaving
all right maybe just uh making sure his
cat doesn't
appear in front of the screen yes
dancing but who does actually like
following the the games of chess
and he wasn't the only pet that followed
the chest pawn chick as well this is
levon aronian's dog
was also a keen supporter but you know
we are asking everyone
for the quiz of the day which famous
athlete would be the best
chess player and we do have some answers
we have a tweet from klaus who says
lionel messi would be the best chess
player imagine
as fast and as clever he's calculating
how to pass those chess pairs he would
be the best
yeah he he would be good wouldn't he and
then we have another tweet from
ew who says he thinks that tom brady the
quarterback
nfl would be a great chess player he's
smart
sharp he rarely blunders and does not
crack
under pressure attacking enlightening
speed and he managed his team attack
against his opponents and then another
answer from victoria now this one i
agree with
usain bolt those pawns will be crossing
the board
really fast maybe we just uh and
tom brady just picking up a poem and
just
throwing it over the board that's
actually a variant a chess very nice
okay so
yeah i i know the nerd the word in
norwegian i think it's clipper shack or
something i don't know what it's called
in english
never heard of yeah you just uh you have
to get your king
you have to throw your pieces or you
flick your pieces oh okay
yeah that one can only be done with a
physical board where you actually have
the pieces to throw them
yeah just try and push them as far as
possible down the board all right um
we did see magnus castle smiling so yeah
i was gonna say maybe he likes the
suggestions from the viewers
well okay so we've seen this for magnus
before
uh early days and early in the days in
the knockout stage he's had a good time
he's enjoying being in the final here
little laugh uh but that has turned out
quite bad for him
previously sort of losing focus and then
eventually uh losing games
right so i mean there's laughter has
been a little bit of a bad omen you know
it must be
it must be like a balance though cause
you want to be in a good mood right you
want to have fun playing you want to
enjoy being in the final
but you don't want to lose focus of
course no you absolutely do not want to
lose concentration i mean
the the thing is that you do have to be
in a good mood when you play chess i
mean
you have to be feeling super happy
super ready and eager just to enjoy the
game in front of you
but uh i think for magnus i think
there's been some private joke that he's
been finding super funny and i think
that's just just been distracting um
okay so we've had some developments
magnus has been stopped in his
tracks with his idea of expanding those
pawns on the left
yeah but i'm not a real fan of his last
move magnus carlsen
look at that he retreated his bishop but
every move has consequences
white's bishop retreated but the pawn it
was blockading has now pushed forward
um black pushing forward in the center
with his pawn black only had one
bad kind of aspect to his position and
that was the backward pawn it's now been
released
um it's pushed forward so okay white's
knight has entered the center of the
board
nicely placed in the middle there but um
i do expect more trades to happen magnus
carves and maybe
with that bishop retreat white's bishop
stepping back does feel like he's
saying goodbye to any real winning
chances in this game we're going to see
more pawns leave the board
um a couple of trades white now has two
isolated pawns on their left side
neither pawn protects uh each other and
they are easy targets for black's
light square bishop so i'm not a huge
fan of that transition for magnus carson
he's still he's still got things under
control white's piece is relatively well
centralized
and controlling some key squares but the
pawns look pretty ugly and uh
i expect to see more trades quite fully
but having said that
you know white's pawns do look
incredibly ugly i completely agree with
that
but you know there's something to be
said for black's pawns as well they also
look ugly and they're also in the same
colour as the dark square bishop
so it could be kind of like a some
tit-for-tat thing yeah
maybe everything on that left-hand side
will just kind of get dropped off and
then
well then the vacuum cleaner has come on
the board and then we can kind of
kiss goodbye to any winning chances for
either side
yeah and uh i know this is taught in the
rush in the russian school of chess and
all the top players kind of adhere to
this but they always try and think
what do i want to be left up with
eventually one thing i do notice is
bishops they are of opposite color so
they won't be able to
trade themselves off easily because they
do stand on opposite colors
um and they have both have targets for
the pawns we could see the knights
disappear the rooks disappear quite
easily
and if we are ended up ending up with
purely a bishop end game it's going to
be a dead draw meanwhile wesley so
retreating his knight there
black is now threatening one of white's
pawns that knight is eyeing up a pawn
on the edge of the board and magnus
carson says no i'm going to ignore that
pawn
um trying to jump in now with the white
knight there's a huge
threat in the position white's knight is
trying to jump in
and create a fork um if we bring up the
analysis board there's a huge threat by
magnus carson this last night moved
bringing the knight forward
if black gets greedy and gobbles up a
pawn suddenly we see a huge fork
black's rooks are both attacked and the
bishops attacked
black will not be able to save all three
of those at once and
now wesley so maybe he underestimated
this move this knight jumped forward
how is he going to deal with this idea
of the knight jumping further into
black's position
um he's got to take some drastic
measures i think he's going to have to
move one of his riches across
yeah he's done that he's moved his rook
across and
well we could be seeing a lot of trades
happening it looks a bit scary though
for black surely if if i just drop my
knight into the position
attacking two pieces you have to move
your rook that's the most valuable one
but
suddenly you've got to be a bit worried
i can take your knight maybe
yeah um black has to wesley so has to
worry about all of these cap
captures and um okay wesley so looking
up there but magnus carson
it's his move he's got to decide how to
initiate these uh these trades
maybe there's a way to turn it in
white's favor slightly yeah so magnus
could now make a decision and we'll
maybe see it in his next move if
he will fight for a win in this game yes
i think
white is out of danger if he just wants
to make a draw now magnus carlsen
he'll drop his knight into the position
then he'll trade a bishop for a night
he'll take off his opponent's bishop
everything will just disappear from the
board but maybe there's a way for white
to play for a win and magnus carson
knowing him he'll try if it's possible
if there's not too much risk
okay he takes the knight first um
that was a little bit surprising that
one i i expected the night dropping
because it's just so tempting
to attack the rook and the bishop
simultaneously but okay bishop takes
knight
and we're expecting porn takes bishop
and
now we have a really curious suggestion
where it's night against bishop
and those two white pawns are still on
light squares
which could be something that uh
white has to deal with but there is an
issue another issue as well which is
that
white's king is way better placed yes
than black's king
and that is something i think
definitely zanzibar is uh
right now he's looking down smiling
seeing now he was like
cuddling with like with his cats yeah
maybe that's what magnus was laughing
about maybe he saw on wesley's camera
that he was
he was distracted there we go wesley so
in a very very good move
uh good mood sorry and okay good mood
but magnus makes a good move
magnus there just pushing a pawn forward
yes it's on a light square but it does
blunt the effect of black's remaining
bishop black's bishop was on a long
diagonal it was actually attacking an
undefended pawn
so magnus carson um the way to play
against bishops is to shorten their
diagonals often
if you block them with pawns um then
that is the way to just
completely nullify their effect
meanwhile wesley so says
okay your move blunted my bishop but it
doesn't threaten anything so the black
king steps across
um the white knight is temporarily a bit
better than
better than the bishop the white knight
is on an outpost protected by pawns it
cannot get kicked away by pawns
um black never really wants to play
bishop forward and bishop takes knight
because that would actually allow white
to
improve his own pawn structure so the
white knight dominates the black bishop
right now
but the promise there's no immediate
targets there are no
real weaknesses in black's camp so one
good piece for white but
that's the only real difference right
now yeah and
the black king is making its way to the
center sharpish
so um yeah things are definitely looking
like they're going
to fizzle out what do you predict ivanka
draw yeah i draw after several moves of
magnus
trying i think he will try
um he does have the option as well of
starting to push some
pawns forward on that right side on the
king side um
because well what else is there to do
frankly um
well if magnus cross was about to do
something maybe this is the moment
because it definitely seems wesley so
it's distracted by his cat here
so maybe magnus could well he spent a
lot of time on this move
make something super surprising and
difficult for wesley
yeah that's that's the hope and that's
why magnus carson he's thinking quite a
long time on this move
and he's been going for a minute and a
half here because he's looking for that
surprising move
looking for that way to imbalance things
at the moment the pawn structure is
completely
completely symmetrical both sides have
pawns which
i mean just playing copycat uh
essentially and if you
imagine the knight and bishop
disappearing the game is a dead draw
there's just no
real imbalance left and that's why
magnus he knows he needs to seize the
moment somehow and
push forward but how to do that without
any risk and knowing also that wesley
keeps winning his white games then that
means magnus needs to win his white
games
so it's probably not an easy decision
emotionally as well to just say no i'm
gonna go for a draw here yeah
well what does this move mean um his
last move
with white shows that he's pushing
forward okay he's trying to be ambitious
magnus carson
notice he's also shortened the diagonal
of that black bishop even further black
bishop now is just staring
at those most well the strongest pawn in
the board
uh black bishop just hitting against a
very well defended pawn so the black
bishop is a terrible piece
magnus carson also stepping forward with
the white king um
he's just positioning himself nicely but
the thing is there's no immediate
follow-up so
um we'll be looking for magnus carson to
somehow create
maybe another square for his knight
maybe create some imbalance on that
right side
um yeah i mean you mentioned it kaya not
only is wesley so super strong with
white but magnus he's been struggling in
this tournament
with black he's lost several games
against daniel dubois with black
several games um maxine vazquez with
black
magnus in this tournament at least his
black repertoire has looked a bit shaky
and uh yeah i think starting off well
here for white
with white will be huge for the world
champion if he's unable to do that he's
going to be under pressure
quite early on i think yeah i mean the
thing is though
it is game one and uh early days so
is it is it actually um an advantage to
start out with black
in matches like this that you can have a
slow start and not
sort of need to win game already in the
first year yeah
i think it is an advantage to start with
black because then you do know
what you need to do with the white
pieces because yes it's true that black
always
has the ability to surprise white but
white usually
sets the scene you know is it going to
be a solid game is it going to be
risky sharp you name it white can choose
that
and well here you can see that wesley
is living up to his uh solid
nickname and has advanced a porn
but you know that that poor move though
it does gain space
it also has some consequences and the
consequence is now that there is a
second square available to the white
knight
or even a rook yep um black's last move
pushing this pawn forward
has weakened squares and this square now
is very very weak
why could potentially later on drop his
knight back and try and re-route it into
this square
you can imagine if some moves are made
this knight on an outpost black never
wants to capture this knight
because suddenly this is a protected
passport look at this pawn chain for
white this is the ideal pawn structure
pretty much
and black has isolated pawns which are
very weak right now so this is going to
be a long-term goal of magnus carlsen
in the current position though um he's
pushed forward all of white's pawns now
um well most of white's pawns on light
squares
um whoops sorry they're all on light
squares pretty much they are going to
block out the effect
of black's bishop uh black's bishop is
going to have no
targets for the rest of the game but
magnus he still needs to create a
weakness
in black's position wesley just shifting
his rook across just waiting there yeah
mostly so i mean would you be tempted
you know because we did actually see
magnus do this
would you be tempted to sacrifice the
rook and just go
you know what i want the target so i'm
going to do that by
radical means and i'm going to put my
rogue
onto a square defended by the black
bishop and my idea is
i will then get my target and i then get
control over
squares because after all that night is
stopping
the rook from uh occupying the line
anyway
yeah um okay we've seen magnus push
forward
um if we bring up the board we can show
ivanka's idea here and i think we might
see this maybe not right now but a bit
later on if black just waits
um the idea would be to drop the rook in
the middle of the board sacrificing it
for the black bishop but suddenly this
knight dominates the black rook
and black has a weak pawn here so if
magnus carson's playing for the win
he'll go for this a bit later on
but the answer i think unfortunately
ivanka is no this isn't happening
if we catch up with the current position
we've seen a couple of rook traits and
magnus pushing forward
he's trying though still to win he's
trying to open lines up
finally on this right side of the board
he's got a great night
black never wants to capture this knight
here um it just improves white's pawn
structure but
he still needs to open things up and
that's why we see magnus carson pushing
on the right side
um meanwhile wesley so retreating with
the bishop mysterious move there
um yeah wesley is just waiting he's
sitting there
he's put his pawns on the best squares
um with black and
now he's just saying to magnus you try
everything i'm going to react
and uh wesley not too worried i liked
your idea ivanka putting the rook in the
middle of the board but
it would have been risky yeah and there
was definitely some risk attached and i
think maybe because it's that first game
yeah this doesn't want to take too much
risk this early on so
um if you were to kind of categorize
these two as football players where
would you put them
the two players obviously pieces magnus
has answered to that later
yeah magnus is a huge yeah huge football
fan magnus carson
so good at fantasy football as well yes
um i think he sees himself as a bit of a
striker maybe an attacking midfielder
number ten yeah yeah i've played with
him enough to know he thinks he's great
in every position
he'll come back to the defense he's a
bit like a full back um
or quarterback he just he likes to
sometimes drop deep take the ball and
then dictate play but yeah
um wesley i see is maybe super solid
centre-back
who can occasionally get into the
opponent's box and score some headers as
well yeah
how would you say like box to box i have
to get these football terms in
maybe like a ramos yes sergio ramos
maybe
oh okay such a ramos definitely not a
dirty player though
that sometimes okay
i think he's got the most goals for a
defender sergio ramos uh in the
spanish league but also the most red
cards
okay well uh magnus moving his rook on
an open line
but yeah we are asking everyone which
famous athlete would be the best chess
player and
again we have some cool answers bag
yashari says i just watched nadal in the
australian open
he plays chess on the tennis court
already he will be fantastic
and then just what's happening i just
see magnus reacting here to a few
is it dramatic what's happening now um
so magnus he's got his rook onto a great
position with white but i think he
missed wesley so's last move
magnus carson not looking very happy
after wesley so just pushing a pawn
forward
and suddenly the white rook is kind of
boxed in it's attacking the black bishop
but that bishop is perfectly defended by
the black king
black also meanwhile has a threat he's
going to drop his black king back
attack the white rook the white rook
actually almost trapped unless it
retreats
and then black's bishop is suddenly
eyeing up pawns on white's left side of
the board
magnus carson maybe just panicking
slightly
he's still in control but he has to be
accurate now wesley so defending
resolutely and magnus low on the clock
maybe that's why he's panicking he's
his inside he's looking cool but inside
he's going to be thinking
i need to be quick i need to be better
and faster yeah but it's not easy david
it's not easy the king steps backwards
and now i think we're going to see
wesley on the counter attack because
those
weak pawns on the left they're on light
colored squares
and the bishop is pointing straight at
them and yep
wesley is attacking the rook and now
magnus must
move that rook and it's not easy to
suggest the square
he's retreated the rook all the way back
and
what is there to stop wesley munching on
pawns
yeah um white i mean it's not looking
good for magnus carson just two moves
ago he brought his rook up the whole way
to the top
and now two minutes later he's had to
retreat it the whole way back down he's
lost two moves essentially
wesley so he can just play uh maybe he
can capture a pawn in the centre of the
board first
but uh also he could play bishop takes
pawn um
one one of white spawns is just dropping
off the board magnus is the one fighting
for his life
in this game the computer still says 0.0
it still thinks white should draw
but once black wins the pawn um it's
only black with his
better bishop now um who can win the
game yeah it's not just better bishop
it's also a better rook
after after the shenanigans they're on
the right side you know i don't really
know what magnus is doing
i mean i i would be a little bit
hesitant about grabbing the pawn
uh the on the right because sorry on the
left because then the white rook can get
mobilized and you know in endgames it's
not just about the quantity of pawns
it's also about the quality
and the further up the pawns are on the
board then
the stronger they become so i would be
looking at doing everything in a
harmonious
way and utilizing my work maybe
improving my king a little bit
yeah and then when the time is right get
snacking get snacky on this once um
wesley so meanwhile he's thinking he
knows there's been a small turnaround at
least psychologically
over the last few moves black was the
one on the defensive now magnus carlsen
will be the one
suddenly on the defensive and wesley can
he adapt to that scenario to put
pressure
on the world champion maybe if there's
one small criticism of wesley in the
past at least
it was that he was happy with draws um
especially with the black pieces against
anyone
um but against the world champion it's
small margins you're gonna have to take
every tiny chance you can get
um that's why wesley so is thinking
right now he's just trying to work out
the consequences
of black grabbing a pawn and being a bit
greedy um
magnus yeah he will have to somehow
readjust
he did miss a move earlier but it does
look like he's oh he has
gone for it directly so he's taken the
pawn and
after trade of pawns in the center the
white rook has
now gone and started attacking the
bishop so wesley has to make a critical
decision here
do you capture the knight and try to
hold on to your extra pawn
or do you just keep the bishop on the
board yeah so black has two
main options i think black will either
play bishop takes knight or the black
rook would drop itself down
give check to the white king um if west
ceso is feeling ambitious he'll play
bishop takes knight but if he's heading
for the draw maybe he'll give check to
the white king and
there's a way to give a few checks maybe
in a row and that would gain wesley a
bit of time on the clock gaining 10
seconds after every move
um or maybe black can also force a draw
immediately if he drops his rook down
giving check um
that would be the safety first approach
i think right now
personally i'd go for the rook check and
then make the decision bishop takes
knight or will we see another check
with black's rook we see another check
the position will it repeat itself
if black moves rook back up one square
that's the second time we'll have seen
that position
um wesley if he's feeling ambitious he
can still play on he can bring his rook
across one square
give a different check but at the moment
it does look like white king knight and
rook are just too active
magnus carlsen being down upon but he's
got enough compensation
so it's up to wesley now to decide if he
wants to agree to
go into a repetition and the draw yeah
it's up to wesley but
just position wise on the board and now
also on the clock one minute down
it does look like most sensible option
for wesley well well well
david he is uh taking your second advice
and now he's
given a different check and the king is
sidestepped and now the bishop has moved
and now
okay there's gonna we're gonna see
action again because uh
magnus now can capture the pawn but uh
so can wesley
yeah i i mean i love that decision just
playing on um while they're still pieces
on the board there's always still life
and wesley so um
not showing any fear against the world
champion he's going for the win for
black he's still temporarily a pawn up
with his last move the bishop the black
bishop and the black broker now eyeing
up white central pawn
um so we'll see that okay magnus carson
restores parity
on the board he gobbles up one pawn uh
wesley so meanwhile
takes one of white's pawns and look at
the black rook it's now actually
attacking both of white's remaining
pawns
um so magnus carson should be able to
hold this because lots of
lots of pieces pawns are disappearing
off the board but yeah it's still white
who's got to force the draw
the pressure's still on him to show that
he can hold this game
so he's not going to win this game it's
not possible for white barring a miracle
or blunder
white will not win this game and in fact
one natural move in this position maybe
if we can bring up the board and show it
is if white were to attack the bishop
um yep with the rook with the rook
uh yeah down yeah it doesn't really
matter it doesn't quite matter it
doesn't matter where you attack but say
you should
yeah okay so now it's possible for black
to actually take
a pawn um yeah this one
yeah okay and if rook takes bishop there
would be a nasty
double attack here and this is the kind
of stuff white has to watch out for
that's why he didn't go for this option
and that's very nice actually ivanka i
missed that
yeah it should be the other pawn but
nevermind here oh okay it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter
either way but um if we catch up with
the game um if we catch up with the game
right now
we've seen magnus carson he has lost his
pawn on the side of the ball so magnus
now two pawns down
but he has improved his knight his
knight is slightly more centralized now
at least guarding one pawn and it's
white who can decide which pawn to grab
right now we might see a scenario of
black having
only one extra pawn and that should but
not be enough to win the game
the way black will win this if he can is
to somehow get this pawn rolling down
the board because it's the
it ends up on a light square and that
will be supported by
his bishop um it's not going to be easy
magnus just deciding now
personally i captured maybe this pawn
just to have some own uh some of my own
play
um down this side of the board but
magnus he's got two pawns to choose from
which will he take um he should hold the
draw but
uh still pressure i would take again i
would follow your advice take the pawn
which is uh protecting your own pawn and
uh just keep the game double edged why
not yeah you predict correctly you've
anchored yeah well
um no he's taking one point he's also
eyeing up this point black now kicking
away the white knight
this knight needs to find a square there
are traps in the position if you move
to the wrong square maybe you'll end up
getting attacked maybe a double attack
here
um this might be okay for white but you
definitely don't want to allow any
tricks in this position so
magnus carson he is the one still on the
defensive
we see him leaning in he knows he needs
to be super accurate to hold this game
with white
all right um pressure's on for magnus
carlsen and his clock's ticking down to
one minute and we know what happens when
the the players reach under one minute
that is when
panic starts to set in um yeah you have
to be a super cool customer
not to feel any kind of pressure out
whatsoever when your clock is ticking
down
to the seconds yeah and white knight has
actually just put itself
on pretty much a horrible square but
it's heading to somewhere better
that's the most important thing a white
knight dropping itself to the edge of
the board we normally hate that
also the same color as the white king so
it might potentially be
uh open to a double attack by black's
bishop but
the knight is heading to a central uh
centralized square and wesley with his
last move attacking the white knight
attacking that pawn at the remaining
white pawn but white's knight now
centralizing itself
to a great square and uh magnus carson
it does look like he's found a way to
hold this game he's put his knight on a
far better square now white's pawn will
drop off at the edge of the board but
black's central pawn is
right for the picking and um it's
checked right now white king will simply
retreat and wesley so he can't hold both
of his pawns
to win here you normally need two extra
pawns in this type of position
wesley so he only has one extra opponent
okay yes
one pawn on its own no it's not enough
and uh you can see
there's been a whole series of trades
and uh that is it
knight i think king this is bishop in
king and the game will just
fizzle out to king versus king and that
is a draw so
uh intense tense battle to begin with
slow start
to the final between minus carlsen and
wesley so magnus carlsen with the white
pieces he definitely wanted a win
in his first game but it is a draw and a
slow start to the final
all right well it is wesley so he's got
now 15 minutes to prepare for his
first white game we do know that a lot
of the games end up
with wins for the person with white
between these two
so magnus do you think he's uh
especially prepared
for these games with the black pieces
ivanka yeah i think he has to be
prepared for the
because he has been struggling you know
against dubois
and against uh maximum vaccine grove on
the second day
that was his achilles heel so he
definitely
has to be ready and willing to fight
because wesley is now going to turn
on the heat and play some very sharp
stuff
but it was a cool start for both of them
david you said
from the beginning this is looking very
drawish at some point though
uh i don't know if it was wesley who
made the move or magnus made the move
but you said okay now it's interesting
and it could be good for wesley what
happened there
yeah it almost turned around at one
point wesley so seizing the moment
and going for the win and that all
started and we saw it on magnus carson's
face
with a bit of a mysterious move i
wouldn't say a blunder just an
inaccurate move by magnus carson
the white rook looking pretty on this
open line it did end up bringing itself
up
to the top of the board attacking
black's pawn but maybe
magnus carson just missed the fact that
the pawn would move forward
this rook now is redundant it has no uh
i mean it simply has nothing to do on
this square and we saw a couple of moves
later after white pushed forward the
black king stepped back
attacking this rook this rook was forced
to retreat the whole way back
so magnus carson losing two moves for
free and
um wesley so now suddenly grabbing a
pawn and going a pawn up
black's bishop also becoming far better
than it's been for the rest uh for the
previous
part of the game wesley so he was the
only one who could win here
we saw a few moves later white attacked
this bishop and black's rook suddenly
dropping down
into the game was he so he had the
option to draw here he could have gone
for a repetition of moves by bringing
his rook up he played for the win by
bringing his rook across
he got close but not quite close enough
magnus carson
just stepping into reverse gear and
holding the draw but
wesley so he'll be very happy with the
way the first game went
[Music]
they are tied after one game in the
final in the opera euro rapid
and we do know wesley so with the white
pieces in the next one he is fierce
with the white pieces so magnus carlsen
he needs to shape
up
all right it's a bit of a slow start to
the final but we know what happens after
slow starts ivanka
storm exactly i mean it's like it's
building up to that final moment
yeah definitely kaya i think we're gonna
see fireworks i mean we've seen it
before from their match in the skilling
open
so i really wouldn't be surprised if uh
wesley turns on the heat
and uh starts scoring scoring you said
it euranko we're talking about football
and sports today as well uh david and
you haven't mentioned it magnus carlsen
he's super
interested in especially football
fantasy premier league
can you tell us what is fantasy premier
league that we keep hearing about
yeah so fantasy premier league it's a
very addictive game
where you choose a team of players and
you just try to predict who's in the
best form who will score the most goals
which defenders
will help to keep a clean sheet you
basically you pick your ideal players
for those positions and magnus carson
he's one of the best
in the world at fantasy football he
actually topped the rankings i think
there were seven million players
eight million eight million and he was
number one last season for a while
um yeah he's uh not just a chess player
magnus carson
this is uh the current fantasy premier
league team actually that we just saw
for magnus carlsen he is right now
number
i think 30 000 in the world this season
but still that is amazing with
eight million players okay but uh
he is a chess player first and foremost
and we did have this idea
our reporter uh oscar brilliant had this
idea to ask magnus
about what would be his fantasy chess
team so choosing chess players
uh current or historical chess players
in a football formation and we're going
to start with the first one
and that's going to be about defense
welcome to
[Music]
welcome to a skill asking
magnus we know you're a big fan of the
fantasy premier league football we have
a challenge for you
we want you to combine your love for
chess
with your interest for fantasy i'll go
with uh
343. the keeper should also be super
solid
right yeah the keeper uh i think we will
put
a contemporary player uh in goal
we will put mr anish kiri
okay yeah he's a good player who rarely
loses but um but he also doesn't
doesn't win win enough games or
tournaments to warrant the place in
in in the outfields
[Music]
an obvious choice there at the back i
will go for
tiran pedrosan um the former world
champion
who he's gonna get you
a lot of clean sheets he will get you
some
attacking attacking returns uh uh
as well so i feel like he's uh he's an
obvious choice
i will also go with a less
less obvious choice there which is uh
mikhail okay in the defense
which seems a little bit
counterintuitive but the thing is
that in a later part of his his career
he had two of the longest unbeaten
streaks
uh of all time very decent security
there at the back while also providing
quite a lot of attacking and then
of course we have another famous almost
invincible player
who is capoblanca rarely ever
loves games and he seems like the
perfect
defense guy okay very good so now we
have
the keeper and three in the back thank
you catch you later
[Music]
so now we know what players magnus would
keep in defense in terms of
chess players and their styles and we
have a very exciting guest
that we're bringing on right now his
name is andreas sanbu
and he is a friend a former actually
football teammate
of magnus carlson andreas hi hi good
evening
good evening um we did see i don't know
if you saw we did see magnus
picking out his fantasy defense chess
team
and i know you're a big chess fan as
well what did you think of his choices
here
yeah i think he knows that chess player
is a lot better than me
so i guess i'm not in a position to
really question his choices but it seems
good
totally defense and good reasoning for
the choices
and andreas so you are i mentioned you
are a team former
teammate and also actually the coach for
magnus carlsen in
a team in oslo you guys called yourself
uh was it fremont from augusta i think
yeah correct and we do know we we've
seen magnus uh
when he's playing chess there a lot of
emotions what was he like when he played
football
well um to start with emotions uh i'm
pretty happy that it's not as emotional
in football as policies in chess
after the games um
[Applause]
yeah here we see so i think this this is
a footage from
when this team frame out from augusta
you you uh
you won a game and you actually uh went
off the league is that correct
yeah it was in 2014
uh we got promoted from uh the seventh
level to the sixth level in the
norwegian
uh pyramid
wow and how are you yes that was amazing
how important was magnus for you to have
that achievement
on the football pitch it's of course
important
um we are a group of maybe a bit
too few players so we are dependent on
everyone uh
to to contribute and play so it's
important of course
um and i think this was like right after
he won
one of his world championship titles so
we sort of went straight from that
to play football with you guys yeah it
is uh
i think it's a month or so before his
second
uh world title wow
um and then okay so what position was
minus on the football field
what was sort of his strengths
i heard david say that magnus i would
love to see himself as a classic number
10.
to be honest with you his skill set is i
might not be
those that's of a classic number 10. um
he's a hard worker he's aggressive he
runs a lot
um he likes to tackle uh he's got a
good cross and good passer of the ball
we have deployed him mostly as left full
back or left side on midfield
he's a good player but his style wise
he's not a
maradona or a francesco totsi is maybe
more like
marcelo andy robertson are maybes
compared to john anderson
i guess i'm sorry maybe it's just
compared to me or most chess players
that he looks like maradona
well but okay you also been a football
coach andreas uh
for this team with magnus is there
anything like relatable
uh playing football maybe the way you
see the field
uh and chess where we know magnus is the
best in the world
yeah you know you hear a lot of times
football experts
commentators they often compare
those tactical football games to a match
of chess
um i think at our level it's
our football matches is just as
comparable to roulette i think
you just start to play close your eyes
and hope for the best but
at the top level of course there's a lot
of trying to figure out
your opponent's next move and try to
analyze
play and counter play and that kind of
dimension of the game so
yeah i guess uh football has some
uh comparable traits to chess but i
think
a lot of sports team sports do so i
don't think it's specific to football um
and you are a friend of magnus you
mentioned the teammates
i'm really curious so when you meet up
with magnus is it like
only chess and football he wants to talk
about all the time
no it isn't and i think we very
uh rarely speak about chess because for
manganese to talk to me about chess at
least
the game and the positions and the moves
it must be the most boring thing for him
because
the difference is level in level is so
huge that it must be like
talking to a toddler or something like
that so we we don't
talk about chess that much uh of course
we talk about
uh stories around chess and we talk a
lot about football we watch football
games together from time to time and
but of course we talk about other stuff
as well as all friends do
um what's happening
experiences other people politics yeah
different stuff so he's a normal guy
then i guess
yeah well as chess players we fancy
ourselves as deep strategies stress
decisions
uh is magnus in charge of the team's
[Laughter]
even if he's strategy good at fantasy
football as well
yeah maybe we should give him some
responsibility for tactics as well yeah
uh of course he's uh he's a great
tactician in chess and fancy people as
well so
might be a very good job and andreas
i've watched a football match actually
with you and i know how passionate you
are about sports
um we do have a quiz question of today
and we are asking
which athletes you think would make
great chess players do you have
do you have an answer there yeah
i thought about that um and of course
it's a difficult question but
i think to be a great chess player you
have to be calm
you have to be patient
you also have to have this accuracy uh
you have to be pinpoint accurate and uh
also to be a bit daring um i think a
sport
where you have to have these uh skills
is a snooker
and the most spectacular snooker player
ever
um and probably the best player ever who
also makes him
some kind of nice aggression is rocket
ronnie o'sullivan
i do not know if he even knows the rules
of chess
as a personality and skill set it would
be interesting to see
ah i met him once he's a cool guy wow i
think
steve davis a former snooker player he's
very passionate about chess so
yeah maybe some similarities between the
two sports
well maybe great answer then andreas and
such a such a great time to have you on
board here thank you so much for joining
us and
giving us a little bit of insight on
magnets behind the
chests and and just in the normal life
thank you pleasures mine have a nice
evening thank you you too
thank you all right that was cool i like
that hearing about my magnus is on my
football pitch and just when he's
hanging out with his friends
um and a very good answer i thought from
andreas sir about
our quiz of the day yes i i didn't think
about snooker players but i mean it does
make sense you know
and david mentioned steve davis and i
know he was the president of the english
chess federation
because he was super interested in chess
and what made me laugh though
um from andreas interview was the fact
that you know we really do fancy
ourselves as excellent
our strategy and just to hear that nope
no way
is magnus in charge of team strategy
he's super interesting to me
all right um it's starting game two in
the final between magnus scrolls and
wesley so
we're gonna head right into that i think
it's only seconds away from starting
with
wesley so having the white pieces magnus
carlsen sitting down
he didn't get that win in the first game
with the white pieces
and we do know wesley so he's going to
try to get that win with the white
pieces here david
yep definitely wesley so he always feels
more comfortable
especially against the top players in
the world when he has white wesley
he can serve with both hands that that's
what we say he can play any type of
opening
um so what will he have in store for the
world champion he does
open the game with his king's pawn
magnus replies also with his kings pawn
so a bit of symmetry here
at this early stage will we see wesley
so okay he plays
an opening called the italian game this
one both sides
are supreme experts in this opening
both sides play this position okay we're
going for super aggressive
play by uh wesley so i was about to say
it's going to lead to a long strategic
maneuvering game but no
white has gone straight on the attack
white has actually won a pawn
we called this the fried liver attack at
least what white was trying to do is the
fried liver attack
um and now white is a pawn up had to
retreat a bishop there but look at this
this is a crazy black has a knight on
the edge of the board white has a knight
in black's half
um white already a pawn up anything can
happen here it tends to end up
quite chaotic these type of positions
are you tricking us like simon the other
day
talking about chess and fishing the book
and you're bringing up an opening yeah
it's true is true fried liver and uh we
do have some really weird
names for openings um that's not the
worst one actually
oh what is the worst one the monkey
the monkey's bum the monkeys there's
also the uh frankenstein dracula
yeah and the halloween gambit yeah
um so okay meanwhile play it's
normalized slightly but wow look at that
magnus carson giving up a second pawn
magnus cast both sides going on the
attack here magnus carlsen
pushing forward his pawns on that
right-hand side in front of his own
black king
magnus wants to attack here he's given
up two pawns to do that but the thing is
i think i've
seen wesley so win with this opening
before as white so i'm a bit worried
yeah he's played before he's played it
and won
it yes yes and i remember wesley so in
that game before he came up with a
really brand new idea
to win and wow wesley so he's just
sacrificed tonight
um both players have done their homework
here
so does it seem that magnus has also
looked at that game
that wesley played and won he must have
done surely i mean he's a world champion
he had to have done his research
the thing is wesley so he's played this
so quickly so confidently
right now white has given up a piece
white sacrificed a knight
in return getting three pawns that being
said anything could happen here black's
king is actually pretty open right now
black's knight on that left side of the
board as well it's
pretty offside it's not defended um
white's queen
very nicely placed well both of black's
knights are huge targets
personally i i love this opening this
position at least for white
um despite what the computer says the
computer says black has a small
advantage but magnus carson he's stopped
to think now
which is not a good sign so if this was
a football game would it be like five
minutes into the game we already have
two red cards and a penalty that was
missed and just pretty much
it's still equal score but everything's
happened already yeah wow
amazing wesley so bringing his a-game
and his
showman to the final here look at that
wesley so he's now got almost three
minutes more than he started the game
with
yeah he's played every move instantly
and look at magnus carson's face yeah he
he's desperately trying to remember
something and
it's not a good omen when you play what
you think is a super sharp opening
you are well prepared and then your
opponent does this to you um yeah bad
news for magnus and he looks so
confident there wesley so just a small
little smile on his face
very relaxed as magnus carlsen is
desperately you said today we're trying
to calculate and remember
yeah and um i know that when i looked at
wesley so's game previously in this
opening
i was super impressed wesley so's
opening preparation went
very deep he went very fast the game he
pretty much won that previous game
purely on the back of his own
preparation his own research with white
and magnus carson the fact that he's
slowed down that he's thinking means
maybe
he's just a bit less well prepared here
maybe his coaches
didn't predict this with him in advance
um
we see magnus closing his eyes he's not
unhappy he's just trying to recall
stuff and that's always a double-edged
sword in rapid chess you don't have
enough time
to sit there and just try and pull back
that memory and work out what's going to
happen over the next 10 moves
you need to be 100 sure you need to know
things in advance yeah this is
especially in such a crazy position
this is just an insane position so you
absolutely do
need to know absolutely everything in
the position and uh
yeah i'm very worried that magnus is
struggling to recall the theory but you
know
okay you've got to be practical if you
can't remember what you have to do you
have to just
work it out should he start freestyling
now we know magnus
his intuition is amazing yeah should he
start now trusting that and just forget
about trying
so hard remember the problem is that
this position isn't
so much intuition it's more about brute
force you know you just have to
calculate
and the first thing you have to address
with the black pieces is what are you
going to do about the night that is
under attack that is under attack all
the way
on the left side of the board so you
have to move it
or if you're not moving it you have to
come up with some kind of counter play
yeah and uh yeah if we bring up the
analysis board we can see why magnus is
thinking right now
he does have this huge problem of this
knight it's offside it's not defended
it's currently
being attacked as well so when in doubt
just retreat a piece this would be a
very sensible move
for magnus carson that being said the
knight is on a terrible square right now
i have a feeling wesley so would
continue attacking pushing forward
kicking this bishop back he would bring
his other bishop forward there's some
ideas now potentially against black's
king
um the reason magnus carlsen is thinking
here is okay he plays this move
eventually i
think he was debating whether to
sacrifice that knight and go on the
counter-attack but he said no
safety first it's better to just keep my
pieces intact and try and weather
weather the storm try and defend the
reason i
prefer white's position here though is
because yes he's got a knight less
but look at these two central pawns
super strong the black king as well
lacking protection protection so if
white can somehow for example
in that variation i mentioned start
bringing his pieces towards the black
king
black is the one on the defensive at
this early stage and uh yeah let's see
whether wesley so has prepared for that
last move that night retreat
yeah i mean he just looks like he's in
calculation mode so i absolutely think
this is definitely in preparation i mean
you do not go into position a piece down
without knowing how to continue an
attack
so uh i do think wesley is just in a
recall mode and
we're going to see a flurry of moves um
yeah
so wesley what kind of football player
would he have to be now
yeah i mean i know i said center back
earlier
strong centre-back but um the way he's
playing in this game he's
maybe a flamboyant winger i don't know
um he's showing off all those tricks
those step overs those skills
um but he still needs that finishing
technique and um yeah
well actually we have another video with
magnus carlson talking about
his fantasy chess team the next one that
we'll have after this game is about
midfield and i can just have a little
teaser about wesley soap
almost making the team for minutes
this was obviously recorded before the
tournament before magnus knew
he wouldn't face wesley in the final
yeah we do have a sporting theme
throughout the day because we are also
asking everyone at home
which athlete would be the best chess
player
you can tweet your answers using the
hashtag chess champs
and uh one answer i i think kai you will
like but
not sure everyone will be happy in the
studio because mr dodgy says
which athlete would make the best chess
player clearly it's famous norwegian
skier
david
mr dodgy i will get my revenge that is a
genius answer actually
yeah and uh well you did ski with
athlete
uh former olympic gold medalist axel lin
swindell
he did play chess against magnus carlsen
it wasn't
um maybe we wouldn't choose him for best
chess player he did struggle
quite a bit he was quite new to the game
and he survived a long time
he improved a lot in a short amount of
time exactly like i mean i had a
one-hour chess lesson with him and
from the start to the end he'd improved
massively and that's true i'm
pretty sure if he put his mind to it he
could uh he could be a decent chess
player yeah
yeah yes you know what i think there's a
lot of things to link
sports and chess i mean after all chess
as a category is actually quite
difficult
to kind of quantify you know there's
this big discussion what is it is that
art is it a sport is it a science is it
whatever
and uh i mean it has the qualities of
absolutely everything
so it doesn't surprise me that uh
athletes
make good chess players well in this
game is this is this simply a sports
game uh of chess david with the way that
wesley has just
given magnus a lot of problems here yeah
it's a bit of everything i mean it's
gonna heat up into
definitely a bit of a sporting battle
but the initial stages were quite
scientific from wesley
he'd clearly done that preparation with
the computers he'd analyzed all of the
opponent's possible replies
he kind of narrowed down the options and
um it could also
still end up as a bit of a masterpiece
an art form
a work of art because wesley so if he
does finish off this game
i mean that's the most satisfying way to
win in chess to sacrifice a piece to go
on the attack
um and meanwhile we see wesley so he
does do that he pushes his pawns
on that left flank and um look at the
night we mentioned earlier it was on the
edge of the board it's retreated but
that black knight is now pretty much
trapped
there is an offer of a pawn in the
center of the board right now
and will magnus carlsen capture it um if
we bring up the board we can see
uh magnus carson right now he's going to
be debating two very tempting moves he's
going to be debating whether to capture
this pawn with his knight
or with his queen um there are flaws to
both of those moves however i think
um if he captures with the knight
suddenly the white bishop will appear on
this diagonal and look at this a bit of
a pin
and the queen the white queen and the
white bishop using teamwork
and they're going to create chaos along
that diagonal if meanwhile magnus
carlsen captures with the queen
he will get punished we'll see a queen
trade white bishop will jump out
check um the black king has to move and
suddenly
look at this two bishops along the two
diagonals creating this kind of
razor effect laser effect even and um
yeah white simply is winning um so
magnus carson
greed is not good in this position he
cannot capture this pawn with his queen
or his knight
i expect him maybe to start freeing up
his pieces he needs to get these ones in
the game
and one way to do that would be to push
his pawn forward and get his rook active
along this line
um so many options though so much to
work out in advance for magnus carlsen
and
lots of traps for him to avoid at this
early stage yeah
very unpleasant because uh wesley's last
move
doesn't look entirely natural to me i
mean i i very much expected the bishop
to come out
attacking the night just as you
suggested and it's very unpleasant that
you you you expect that move
and then something else comes on the
board you're like oh okay
well okay back to the drawing board and
uh i agree with you that pawn in the
middle is just too hot to take you
cannot grab that one
yeah i mean you're just you're king
the thing is though black's king is
totally
open and you just cannot let it get
exposed even more and you certainly
cannot let any of white's pieces come
close
um how would you start repairing the
positions black
you ask the toughest question i mean it
is i mean because i i couldn't
clearly see something to do um it's a
super tricky position to handle with
just 10 minutes on the clock
i think with 10 minutes left i would
rather uh instead of trying to repair
the position i'd rather build my own
time machine and go back and play a
different opening
because this position is just so scary
um for black
for magnus carson and um yeah i mean
despite having that extra night black
piece is just really bad
his king is exposed along those
diagonals that we mentioned and
um yeah i mean it doesn't help being
four minutes down on the clock as well
when your opponent is clearly
much more familiar with the position
than you are three minutes now for
magnus carlsen and he does make that
move that you mentioned david
yeah i think it's the best move uh so
magnus carson finding a good move in
that position and wesley
this is just pure preparation he's
definitely seen this position before i
reckon
um pushing forward with his ball not
allowing the black rook to open itself
up
along that line that's very instructive
what wesley so has done
and uh another instructive point i think
was um
kind of on the same line as ivanka was
saying we expected him to bring out his
light squared bishop wesley so with
white
to try and target the black king but
sometimes keeping an idea in store for
later is much more
unpleasant for the opponent than using
it immediately if you use it immediately
your opponent can defend and
they'll be able to predict things in
advance now magnus carson always has to
worry about
the threat um bringing that bishop out
the threat is stronger than the
execution
white's keeping everything in reserve
white's pieces a lot of them on the
bottom rank there
but they're ready to spring into action
whereas black's pieces
yeah there's actually only one move i
think to hold
the balance and that is just to capture
the pawn
um if we bring up the board yeah because
if you were to make any move just say
you were to
develop the bishop let's show the
problem
well white will simply play pawn takes
pawn and after bishop takes pawn
now the white pawn would go forward in
the center
and the bishop and the knight would be
forked and the point is is that after
queen takes queen knight takes queen
and uh yeah it's just just
so unpleasant for for wesley in fact the
only
move is just to capture the pawn yep so
the only move magnus costa can play to
stay in this game is to just capture
this pawn
it's it's quite a natural one so i would
expect him to find it but any other move
and pretty much black is busted black is
lost immediately
so he has to play pawn takes pawn and
hope for the best white bishop will jump
forward and recapture
and black still has a problem all these
bad pieces
wow he doesn't find the movie he just
signed it wesley so i don't know yep uh
magnus carson capturing this pawn but we
said
it was poisoned pretty much queen takes
queen now why can't wesley so just bring
out his bishop creatively
he's going to bring out the bishop
wow super dramatic and game two in the
first
uh final match between these two the
first one ended with a draw we knew as
they saw
so would come up with something
fantastic with the white pieces
and he certainly has yeah um wesley so
playing like a genius and
this i mean he's so good with his uh
research his opening preparation that's
why
players hate to play wesley so he's
actually one of the most feared players
on the world scene right now because
it's just hard to survive the opening
against him
um i mean of course he's a fantastic
middle game player he's great in the end
game too but
the opening stage he's so good and so
deadly and
magnus carson it just feels like he's
walked into this kind of
he walked into the snake pit exactly
exactly
no i mean the bishop will just come out
and uh
that's it yeah i think the best magnus
carson can hope for now
is to just give back a piece if white's
bishop brings itself out as we mentioned
magnus carson he'll lose a piece back
but he just has to maybe give that piece
away and try and survive with the queens
off the board
it's not going to be easy wesley so
we'll probably just be a pawn up maybe
even two pawns up for not uh
not enough compensation i don't think
magnus carson
realizes what he's just done with his
last move um
it's not the most obvious move that's
the saving grace magnus carson
there's a lot of tempting options here
for white he could play pawn takes porn
he could maybe trade the queens but if
he brings his bishop out
it's looking good for wesley will he
find that move
but after um 22 moves wesley so has
played so fast
up till now he takes uh a long pose now
to think
two minutes going up to that now so does
that mean that he's finally
out of everything he remembers and now
he too
is freestyling it yeah i think the
reason wesley so is paused is because
probably
up until that last move he's looked at
this position with the computer
but he will have looked at the two best
computer moves maybe and figured out
what to do there
but he will know that magnus did not
play one of the best moves
that is why he's paused for thought now
he's thinking okay the computer didn't
like that move
let's work out why and uh he'll sense
this is a critical moment a key moment
if wesley isn't accurate then black will
survive so that's why he's spending his
time
he's going to try and find yeah
simply the path to punish magnus
carlsen's last move
um yeah wesley so he does have the
luxury of a lot of time to spend
at least and uh he's doing the right
thing he's just trying to knuckle down
and work things out
yeah what do you think ivanka will he
fight will he find that move bringing
his bishop out now
yeah for sure hundred percent i think
he's just uh
calmly it's to me it seemed like when he
saw magnus's move he took some time out
just to calm himself down and not get
over excited and just uh
play the winning idea because i mean you
have to do that
i don't see any other option other than
bringing the bishop out
so this is uh if we bring out the
analysis board we should show
what we expect so i i would expect
something like bishop
comes out to attack that knight and now
if black were to play just say queen
takes queen
knight takes queen and black goes well
that's fine because i can just simply go
knight takes pawn capturing the knight
defending the other night
what's the problem well the problem is
is that white will now come out on the
edge
uh with the bishop and attack that night
and suddenly you see
these amazing potential of those bishops
and uh now the threat is simply to
pick up the light squared bishop and
capture that knight
and there is just no good the other one
the other one
well i think this is a bigger threat
right now yeah yeah sorry yeah
yeah you're completely right in this
particular position in my mind i was
moving the king
if black's king moves that's right one
will capture the other knight maybe
and at the very end he'll capture this
rook black's simply just getting
destroyed along these two diagonals
um look at these two white bishops
they're beautiful pieces these two right
now they're just controlling
everything and death by bishops death by
bishops
um will magnus carson face that death uh
will he have to suffer in this position
when there's no this is
simply no good move for black um or will
he
i mean yeah i mean what else to do um
or will he somehow get a lucky escape a
reprieve if wesley so misses
this idea you do have to look two three
moves in advance i guess for wesley so
maybe slightly further advance if you
want to get to the truth of that
position that's why he's spending his
time now yeah definitely i mean because
it
could look misleading you could just
stop or after um
after the night captures the pawn and
just go well okay that's it
like the knights protect each other but
if you go one move deeper then you'll
see
yes black is totally tangled up
and uh yeah you can just see that magnus
knows that he is in serious serious
trouble
wesley is just a very calm
i mean this is one of the beautiful
things i like about chess is that you
know
both players have access to the board
nothing is hidden you know everything
that wesley sees
magnus sees as well oh okay
well wait one second is this what's
happening wesley
has um he's just slipped up he's blunded
and
he missed his winning move he knows it
look at wesley so
wow he missed this last move wesley so
he blacks bishop now blocking the checks
and we will see a couple of trades and
suddenly white is the one in trouble
um magnus carlsen he would have seen
this advance in advance he played his
move instantly
wesley so leaning back he's he's i mean
he just did not spot this idea from
magnus carlsen magnus carson giving back
a piece
and black should be winning now um i
mean
if maybe we can bring up the board while
keeping an eye on the players faces
because
uh suddenly magnus carlsen we did see
him suddenly put his head in his hands
he realized he was losing
but he got lucky and this move bringing
the bishop out this is what wesley so
missed
black bringing bishop out sacrificing
his bishop back but
if white gets greedy and takes back the
piece we see at the very end
black's knight springs forward attacking
this rook if the rook i mean it just
simply has no good squares
if it captures this pawn then the issue
is look at this rook in the corner
it's been at home the whole game and
suddenly it's trapped black
is winning no matter where the rook goes
if it retreats
he will get attacked and suddenly
there's issues all of white's pieces
look at the quality
they're all asleep on their start
squares this king out on its own
and there's two threats now for black
there's checkmate coming down and
coming down and trapping the white king
or there's checkmate to the rook
even bringing the bishop and winning the
white rook suddenly wesley so
he's going to get attacked and what
magnus carson he's the one
turning the position in his favor wow so
magnus carlsen could now be
winning this game wesley so losing yeah
turn around just in one move um we did
say i mean you've actually said 100
wesley will find out i would have said
pretty much the same um if you'd asked
me i thought wesley he was odds on to
find it but
sometimes the problem with knowing
things too well in the opening
is that as soon as you're surprised you
just it takes you a while to react
wesley played what 22 moves pretty much
instantly
and then as soon as he was on his own he
just uh he went for the wrong option
and this one was tempting but there was
a hidden idea
hidden defensive idea for black yeah and
uh that's uh that's a kind of a painful
missed opportunity
and uh there we are we're looking at uh
magnus carlsen's
air quality and you can see that uh well
it's not great air quality is it you
know the co2 levels are on amber
and this problem with humidity 15.5
percent
the temperature's good temperature is
good um magnus carson
the whole event his humidity has been
slightly off from what it should be but
um yeah the co2 levels may be worse than
they have been all tournament actually
for magnus but
will that come back to affect him later
in the day meanwhile wesley that's
actually pretty much perfect air quality
just the temperature slightly cold there
in minnesota
17 degrees i did actually see a tweet
someone sitting in minnesota and saying
it was very cold there right now
so these two players both sitting in
cold
temperatures oslo and minnesota both
below zero i bet yeah and we did see a
tweet from wesley yesterday i think
holding the air things device and
in the background there was a whole lot
of snow
but are they keeping cool in their heads
well i must say magnus carlsen seems to
have done that in a
very hard game so far yeah keeping cool
and suddenly uh maybe being the winner
of this game
yeah he still has to be accurate though
we had black here i think has to play
knight takes pawn right now
um to kind of press homer's advantage
that's why magnus carlsen
again he's not unhappy right now when he
puts his head in his hands
he is purely calculating or remembering
things here he's calculating he's just
looking ahead four or five moves
trying to make sure that black has the
advantage
um he knows this is still a key moment
yeah i mean both these players they're
ice cored when they need to be
they're cold-blooded when they calculate
when they look for those winning
opportunities but magnus meanwhile he
yeah he survived the worst
essentially is black yeah you're right
david uh he has to
find uh one correct move here otherwise
i think the position is level
is to probably find knight takes pawn
yeah i think it's the most natural
movement
i agree because you're capturing a pawn
you're attacking the rook
and uh if the rook moves to the wrong
place wow
hello there's a lovely diagonal for the
bishop
yep magnus carlsen spending a long time
here which is
slightly uh puzzling because black's
knight capturing a pawn
and attacking a rook at the same time
just looks so good and so simple
magnus meanwhile just maybe just looking
even deep into the position just
double checking everything making sure
um i think this is a good moment to
spend time for magnus because we just
had that turn around that flurry of
moves
but if he ticks under five minutes and
still isn't
completely sure of the consequences then
um then wesley will start to get hope
again well wesley it just seems so
unlike him to blunder
do you think it's the nerves of the
final getting to him yeah and maybe
over excitement just the fact he knew he
had such a great position he knew that
magnus had walked into his opening trap
um walked straight into this kind of
prepared idea and
uh maybe wesley just yeah just
he knowing he needed to punish magnus
but trying to do it in the wrong way
um wesley though he's quite good at
readjusting he's quite good at just
brushing off the
um mistakes and we saw in the skilling
open he twice
on the first day he twice went behind to
magnus he brushed it off and managed to
win the next game so
um still some chances for wesley to
fight back yeah definitely
um yeah i mean this is one of the
reasons actually
um well just by looking at wesley's
mistake is that this is why we do this
whole system of checks captures attacks
make that list
if you make that list you won't kind of
be so fixated of just
calculating one line and just getting
obsessed with that
if you make the list and then choose
then you can kind of at least
have some kind of concept as to what
moves are available
but it's very difficult to do actually
in the heat of the moment
it's difficult to suddenly go wait one
second here
work through those moves i mean most of
the time you're just like oh
i win play yeah and uh
that's what wesley did in this game yeah
maybe
maybe i mean he's amazing player though
i think he just made the assumption that
the knight had to retreat
yeah um he definitely made that
assumption and
maybe that's the big difference as well
between classical chess and
rapid chess classical chess when you
have a couple of hours per game okay
meanwhile
magnus finds the best move but yeah
classical chess you have that time to
sit there
sit on your hands calculate everything
out to the end look for alternatives but
here wesley he thought he saw a winning
idea he went for it but he missed
black's best response
um if he'd stopped and looked gone right
back to the beginning
look for his own ideas he would have won
and oh and the bar shoots up with this
move by wesley is it another small
mistake by him
small mistake the problem is everything
was pretty bad right there
there were no good moves and he's he's
trying to play the move which
makes the position kind of survivable at
least but
um i think now if magnus carson finds
the move just i was going to say i
showed it earlier bringing the rook
across
offering this rook trade look at all of
white's pieces black is trying to trade
off the only white piece which has
actually moved
pretty much and if we see a rook trade
now black is simply winning
white's king we talk about background
checkmates quite a lot but white's king
is completely trapped on his back rank
white's rook it was right up white's
other rook is trapped on that bottom
left-hand corner
um shall we should we bring it up on the
board just to show the problem
so uh yeah
all the other two huge problems
okay so if white were to play just rook
takes rook
uh black would capture and now the big
problem is is that essay
white would play something with the i
don't know suggest a move david
japon takes born okay then black can
play
rook check mate which is an amazing and
we call this
this uh checkmate the back rank mate
because the king cannot escape
from the second for the from the first
row and uh
that if that's not bad enough there's
also another threat in the position
which is if you were just to capture
take take back the rook
and uh say you play something else say
maybe you move the bush
well let's say we stop the checkmate
with a king exactly for example
okay then the bishop would also come
onto the long diagonal
and threaten the white rook
so that rook is trapped there's just no
way out
so those are two of the biggest threats
there are
so what has to be super accurate now how
to handle both
those ideas and uh i think there's only
a couple of moves
to deal with that yeah i think white has
to bring his knight forward simply
defending his rook
and creating an escape square for his
other rook but for example if
black simply i mean there's plenty of
moves here i think a few
strong moves but if he simply plays pawn
takes pawn um white is still in a bit of
a pickle because this pawn is
gonna step forward kick away this knight
and this knight has to stay
defending its fellow rook and also
there's still the idea of bishop to this
diagonal
creating a deadly pin um white knight
white's rooker easy targets
um wesley so he needs to bring his night
out i think that's the only move to
survive but
um even if he plays it it's still big
big trouble ahead
um yeah wesley so now i'm
soon gonna go under five minutes and uh
bad position on the board and
uh yeah it's gonna be a fight for his
life if he saves this so
wesley so he can save anything i think
so we're not expecting him to move his
rook now
well definitely not taking the black orc
that's not what we're waiting to see
from
wesley so he has been thinking for two
and a half minutes now
so it's getting dramatic also on the
clock for wesley so okay
we have the movie mentioned yeah we have
the move okay so
we are expecting magnus just to get
greedy
and capture the porn and after that
wesley is now in serious
serious trouble just look at all blacks
pieces i mean they're just
amazing every single one of them
and uh paul wesley i mean that
that was some fantastic piece of opening
preparation
yeah and it just one small blunder
i know this is this is the cruelty of
chess that you can play
beautifully for 20 moves you can make
absolutely wonderful moves that will
have everyone cheering for you and
giving you applause
and then you make one horrible blunder
and that is it your game has collapsed
and
you lose i love what you said the other
day i mean since we're also talking so
much about
other sports in football today that it's
not like in football you
you can be up five nil and have a little
mistake and that you're
five one years yeah good but in chess
it's not like that at all
one little mistake and this is the
situation for wesley so
and we do see magnus snacking on that
pawn yep
so equal material on the board right now
but the quality of the pieces
all favors black white still has the
problem of the white king vulnerable
along the
the first rank white still has the
problem of the rook in the corner
um huge target there's simply no way to
deal with all of that
quick enough um and magnus carson he
knows just
two or three accurate moves he should be
able to maybe build up a material
advantage
um yeah i mean chess it's ruthless i
mean other sports i think chess
maybe the sport it's mostly similar to
is
tennis but in tennis for example you can
lose a whole set you could lose six love
not even win a point and you still have
a chance to fight back
um you could lose 20 balls in a row and
uh in chess if you make 20 bad moves in
a row
um you'll have lost a long time ago but
why wouldn't wesley so now just take
that blackboard
what am i not seeing yeah good question
kaia if we bring up the analysis board
we can see um the white knight is
actually
overworked right now if it does get
greedy and capture this pawn
it would lose protection over the white
rook and suddenly the white rook would
just simply drop off the board and
there's again
checkmating ideas white's king is going
to be trapped so white's knight cannot
capture that pawn
you still cannot go for the rook trade
first and then capture the pawn
because at the very end checkmate again
this king
is always getting trapped in every
variation
and it has a very important name kaya oh
what is it back rank
mate although when you're when you first
start to
play chess and if you're very young they
always like bank rank
no no
yeah okay we do have the mobile
obviously we do have a move a very good
move from wesley so
bring his bishop out but magnus carson
finds the best reply bringing his own
rook
uh bring his own bishop forward we've
seen a trade uh of knights the rooks are
coming off the board and
in this current position it's actually
still level material but magnus carlsen
is winning simply
because look at these two pawns these
two are simply better than
this one i expect to see magnus push
this pawn forward sooner
or later the other black pawn will start
pushing forward black also has a better
rook than the opponent this rook is
going to come down
and start grabbing some pawns uh so
wesley so he's done his best he's
survived till the end game now
but magnus carlson's still in control
these two are going to beat
this one and we do know that magnus is
the endgame magician
if there is going to be an advantage in
the position he is going to convert it
um yeah david we see that there are some
numbers above the board
can you just tell us what they are yep
so the um
the computer evaluation um above the
board is swung
all the way across to uh to black side
to magnus carlsen's side giving black a
2.4 advantage
that's equivalent to having two and a
half extra pawns pretty much um so
although on the board
it's pretty much level if we catch up
with the current position on the board
it's level
uh same pieces same pawns it's the
quality
uh that gives black this advantage it
means he's odds on to win this game and
here we see these two pawns edging ever
closer to becoming one of them becoming
a new queen at least and
the other numbers we see below the
players names are the clock times
so their time remaining in white and the
time they've used on this move
in the kind of yellow gold color and wow
look at this magnus casting another
couple of moves have entered the board
and these black pawns are so close now
white pushing forward and
um in a few moves time i think
white oh well magnus carlsen sorry has
two winning ideas he's brought his rook
across that is one of the winning ideas
i was going to highlight
there's simply a threat no matter what
white does if he brings his king forward
black's going to step forward with the
pawn
and this pawn's coming if rook takes
bishop the pawn will make a new queen
um next move if pawn takes pawn this
other pawn will make a new queen one of
them is going to become
a lady very shortly and magnus carson
pressing forward with his advantage
wesley so meanwhile just
trying his best to survive his rook
stepped up
just to try and block along the second
rank but it shouldn't be a permanent
uh shouldn't be a permanent defense at
the very least black was
whoops sorry me and my arrows at the
very least
black will step forward with his king to
support this pawn
um later in the game yes is wesley
defending
well here though yes um yeah he's doing
his best
you know but the problem is is if it
ultimately is a loss
then that is the fair result if uh
but you know magnus uh sorry wesley will
be doing his utmost to survive
but uh it's a super difficult ask i
think yeah i mean look at that black
pawn now on the left it's two squares
away
exactly i mean the quality of that pawn
is
so insane i mean just wonderful and uh
look at what color the queening square
is it's a dark square and what does
black have
a dark square bishop you know check
check check everything is working
beautifully yeah actually i think
white's best hope now is to maybe try
and get those bishops off the board
because um black's bishop pacific
mentions covers
the promotion square for black's porn so
it will help shepherd
and guide that pawn through to the end
so white needs to maybe get those
bishops off the board i would
offer a trade of bishops right now okay
he instead moves the king that king's
going in the wrong direction
um it's not going to help on that left
side now and black's king steps in the
right direction
but i expect to see the black king rush
itself over to that left side to help
guide and kind of hold the hold the hand
of that black pawn
um which is going to become a queen
later on in the game
yeah and we're going to see the teamwork
being the dream work
just helping that pawn it promotes and
that's that's the kind of very simple
goal of the position
promote pawns in fact that is like one
of the basic aims in
end games you either want to win pawns
promote pawns
or checkmate the end checkmate or making
new queens that's
tends to be the two most common ways of
winning a game and i mean while okay
white does offer those trades of bishops
black will not allow that trade he will
just retreat his bishop i reckon
or maybe step it forward yeah i would
step it forward right
yeah um if okay he doesn't okay he
retreats the bishop so
so the rook can't get from the rook
can't monitor the
the rogue past pawn from this behind
so yeah interesting move i like it yeah
if we bring up the board we can see
black's last move he did not want to
trade these bishops because then it
becomes harder
to get his pawn to the end of the board
the bishop needs to cover this square to
help the pawn promote later on so he
retreated his bishop
to the best square actually the maybe
the only winning move uh the only
immediately winning move for magnus
carson because he stops white now
giving this check because the black
bishop covers this square
if he had moved his bishop to another
square suddenly white would give check
um and the rook would step behind
guarding this pawn
and the reason black is winning now in
this current position um
is because if white uses his rook as a
blockader this is a very common pattern
a bishop will now step forward and look
at this white rook
it's trapped for the rest of the game
essentially white is playing without
this rook
this pawn and this bishop keep the rook
imprisoned for the rest of the game and
essentially black would just use his
king he'll march it
ever towards this rook and eventually um
he'll yeah
he'll pick up the trapped piece um
wesley so meanwhile uh just thinking
okay i need to get the bishops off the
board
offering this trade of bishops but well
plenty of waste for black to win the
bishops are coming off the board we're
going to see magnus carson retreat his
rook
bring it behind the pawn and we're going
to see a situation like this
this rook trapped and black's king just
going to march itself down and win the
white rook
let's go back to the players i think
we're going to see wesley so resign any
moment now ah
okay he's already going to resign we do
see the bar as mentioned
uh saying a huge advantage for magnus
carl's now
almost six advantage so that's basically
a winning position and it's
not even that hard for magnus to find
that win no
that last move is so classy i think
simon williams the ginger gem he
mentioned it the other day
rooks belong behind past pawns when
they're trying to support them through
because your opponent's rook will have
to blockade that pawn and it will be
paralyzed look
white's rook is going to be paralyzed
now okay and so now all we have to do
is advance that black king all the way
towards that white rook and uh just
watch
it's uh i don't think he even needs to
think too much
it's going to be simple uh for magnus
carlsen first okay
he prepares to bring the black king he
just moves his rook down
this is just being mean yeah i agree
with her david
we do see in the game for the third
place in that match timora jabo has
won his uh second game here against
maximum vascular grouse he is up by
one point that is um the fight for the
third place and this is the fight for
the gold
in the opera euro rapid looking like
magnus carlsen
will get one point up here yeah i mean
look at that by
magnus carlsen with his last move he
blocked off the white king the white
king was trying to sneak in
through that right side black said no uh
magnus said okay i'm gonna stop you
doing that
and then slowly i'm going to make you
run out of moves
white's rook can never ever move because
the black pawn will just march down the
board so look white has to resort to
playing around with his king
playing around with his pawns and when
the moment is right magnus carson will
begin that race he'll bring the black
king over
to that left side of the board and win
the white rook um for a pawn
and uh it's just a matter of time now
wesley so just
he's just saying to magnus okay i know
i'm losing you just
find the winning plan and uh he's
helping us as well he's uh
keeping the game going uh i hate it when
players resign too early
and yeah well magnus has advanced his
pawn that was uh
slight somewhat unpredictable but it's
sneaky because i can see the point
behind it
yeah that is a super sneaky okay well
we're good
okay so white's king tries again to
attack the black pawn but magnus says no
i'm going to close that door to you the
white king has to step back
um magnus he's just trying to make white
run out of moves
um white's rook can never move anymore
white's simply playing with his king and
with his pawns
magnus just trying to suck thee i'm
going to sneeze again
he's totally sucking the life out of
he's just saying to to wesley make your
move
just uh show me what you have okay and
there you go
the king is no well by advancing the
black pawn the king is no longer able to
run and grab some pawns on the right
side
so yeah now all that magnus has
left is to run the king over and it's
either going to be
that king is either going to be munching
on the white pawns on the right
or it's going to be assisting the pawn
on the left
so and that approach completely depends
on white so it's just completely game
over yeah we saw wesley so
shaking his head he'll still maybe play
a few more moves but
the key thing is black has now locked
down that right side of the board that
side of the ball is completely locked
down white has a three versus two
advantage there
but white's pawns are just immobile they
can never push forward
um so black has closed that side of the
board it's all going to depend on the
right side now on the left side sorry uh
black's remaining
extra pawn on that flank if white brings
his own king over
ivanka it's going to be an easy win
right black's just going to take
the pawns on the other side exactly the
king is kind of like
the boss well it's kind of i don't want
to say box to box but you kind of like
super flexible one side the other side
you know take your pick
and uh yeah yeah wesley so just has to
wait with this king in the middle
simply and uh magnus hopefully we'll get
to see the winning plan there of black's
king
stepping down to that left side
eventually um okay meanwhile wesley does
retreat his own king
um black's king steps forward um will we
see wesley so
dart across to that left side with the
white king um
the problem is with positions like this
when you're playing without a piece
white playing without a rook
your king cannot block the opponent's
king because eventually you just run out
of moves
um your opponent will give you the move
and eventually you just have to if you
go to the left your opponent will go to
the right if you go to the right your
point will go to the left
and uh yeah playing without a rook here
what's happening
was shaking his head he went under the
minute there
and it's back the clock is ticking for
wesley so and he's not
looking comfortable yeah black's
advantage is growing look at the white
king
um forced to uh use the king now as a
blockader of black's pawn there on the
left
while the black king is just marauding
into the position
um black's king is gonna do the dirty
work grab all those pawns on the right
side
and magnus he's gonna get killer pawns
on both sides of the board soon
um wesley finally activating his rook
because his king is
taking over the job of blockading
black's pawn on the left there but um
the rook on its own will not be able to
fight the battle against black's king
and black syrup
um look at the black king just entering
into the position
uh white's cannot keep all of its pawns
defended it's too many of them
why did magnus just take that white pawn
good question kai i would have taken it
i think it's just a matter of taste uh
he's going after white's
corner pawn there on the right first um
okay he could have grabbed pawn there
but wesley soul resigns
in the game his first game with the
white pieces we thought
this could be the game that he would win
but it is magnus carlsen
who is the first winner in a game in the
final
the world champion is up by one point
wow and wesley saw he did come out super
strong in this game with a very creative
very dangerous opening
and a blunder ivanka that must be
devastating for him it's annoying
i mean the opening strategy that wesley
so employed was just perfection
he had the world champion on the ropes
and it was looking like everything was
going to be going his way
but yeah one blunder and that was it his
position was completely
unsalvageable did magnus get lucky here
david or
or are you all so impressed with how
magnus carlsen played this game yeah
magnus was impressive
okay his opening he struggled a bit he
walked into his opponent's
preparation but from there um you make
your own luck in a way and
uh once he got an opportunity he never
let it slip that end game once the
queens came off
magnus carlsen back to his best he did
what carlson does and
um yeah once he got an opportunity once
wesley so had slipped up
carson took control and it all started
from
this position magnus actually just
making a mistake playing queen takes
pawn on the last move
offering this trade of queens we know
that has been carlson's strategy
in the past but here wesley so had a
very strong move
he should have brought his bishop
forward creating a pin along this
diagonal
targeting the black knight which cannot
move because the black king is behind it
and we saw it earlier if the queens had
disappeared from the board
yes magnus carson could temporarily
defend these knights clinging onto each
other
but white's other bishop would jump
forward and creating two pins now
these bishops have laser-like precision
just locked in on their targets white is
about to win a piece back
and he would emerge with at least an
extra pawn at the end
um instead though uh wesley so he missed
this opportunity
in this position he traded the queens
but he hadn't looked far enough into the
future
he gave a check now but it's too late
magnus carson giving the piece back
and after a few more trades we saw um
wesley so
struggle in this position the problem is
his pieces are simply asleep
and it took too long for them to get
into the game in the meantime magnus
carson built up that winning advantage
later just cruising through in the
european game
magnus carlsen is up by one point in the
final against wesley so
and with a win in the next one with the
white pieces
he will be the winner of the first match
in the final
[Music]
magnus carlsen he's doing great in the
final right now and we know
he's also doing great in fantasy
football premier league
this is a game where you manage a team
of football players from the premier
league throughout the season getting
points
uh according to how the players
performed during the season
and we asked magnus our our reporter
asked brian asked magnus to
set up a fantasy team of chess players
we did do the defense
in the last break and now we're gonna
see who he picks for his
midfield welcome to welcome to
a skill asking
magnus we know you're a big fan of the
fantasy premier league football we have
a challenge for you
we want you to combine your love for
chess
with your interest for fantasy in
midfield we have
some tricky players you know what we'll
go with uh with another
contemporary player uh wesley so
okay interesting place yeah his uh
general mindset is apparently
fairly defensive and extremely hard to
you know dribble dribble past you can be
poisonous when when he does decide to
uh to attack and you can get your you
get to quite some points
the other two in midfield
they're going to be myself i could be
one of those number eight
midfielders who's just dribbling passing
the ball
running all over the pitch and good work
rate
running good work rate both boxes and
and so on
i will put uh karpov as well he has
great tenacity
uh in in defense and
surprisingly poisonous attacking player
who has a wonderful understanding of uh
of the game yeah we don't have three
central uh midfielders we have two
okay so then zoe is out of the team it's
the wizard
we're actually playing with
i think spassky
is is good he did play with a lot of a
lot of energy though
probably a little bit too creative to be
there but
last year it deserves to be in the key
but lost it
is probably more of a tricky winger but
he's actually playing on a position
unfortunately so he will
have to be a win back who can still use
his uh
his trickery okay so then we have four
players in in midfield
thank you catch you later
[Music]
yeah magnus carlsen seems like he's
enjoying the task given by
oscar here putting himself in the
midfield david
also wesley so barely made it with the
play he showed in that last game should
we so actually been in the midfield
there poor wesley
maybe he'll be the star substitute uh
he'll come on when the others need a bit
of backup they need a bit a bit of a
rest but
yeah magnus knows these guys better than
most and uh can't follow his choices
he's a huge uh football fan magnus
carlson we know he's a fan of real
madrid
and i do think we have some footage from
i think it's 2013 right after he won
his first world championship title he
was invited
to santiago by nobel the home field for
real madrid to take the kick
from the start david i mean i know
you're a football fan as well
yeah i'm so jealous can we i wish we'd
have been able to swap lives just for
one day but uh yeah i mean magnus
i know he met ronaldo he met sergio
ramos he met all the superstars
but i actually saw so after this uh a
lot of those players the huge stars of
real madrid
it was the players from real madrid who
who who posted the selfies with magnus
who sort of
it seemed like they were more starstruck
actually
is this showing what a big star magnus
carlsen isn't in the world
yeah yeah i mean absolutely he is number
one
and uh everyone has uh heard of him or
is beginning to hear of him so
that's super interesting that you say
that kaya that the football players
were the ones he was star struck huge
moment there for
for magnus carlsen and yeah we did see
his midfield there i don't think
uh uh well there was only himself
eventually
as the active player a lot of historical
players there yeah
would you have sort of chosen the same
ones oh
maybe i would have had a few more
contemporary players in there
maybe maybe anand or actually chronic
just retired i wouldn't say kramnik but
um
yeah all of those players they have they
have their strengths those clear
refined styles as well and they're in
there for a reason and himself as the
number
number 10 the way he played this last
game winning
uh actually had a difficult situation
but uh blunder by wesley so yeah
was this a football number 10
performance by magnus cross maybe maybe
the defense
so maybe you should yeah he caught
himself in number eight so he can do
everything
he can attack when it's necessary he can
defend um he defended that
very well once given the chance and then
uh yeah went on the attack in the end
game
and i like the fact he's next to karpov
i think those two have very similar
chest understandings
um carp off definitely he would control
the game he would see the opponent's
threats their attacks before they even
arrived
on the pitch and uh but i really like
that he's chosen some very very
historical figures you know it's like
some homage to the past
because i don't i must admit if i were
asked the question i would probably
stick to
the last 50 years i wouldn't they'd be
thinking of players from
from that long ago yeah and i think for
the viewers at home
um they might not be so familiar with
some of the names but
there's so much to research out there
and you'll learn a huge amount uh about
chess about chess history and uh it'll
improve your game if you go and research
those players in magnus's team yeah
some fantastic chess players and some
fantastic athletes out there ivanka and
we're asking our viewers about this
today
yeah we're asking which athlete would
make the best
chess player which famous athlete that
is you can tweet your answers using the
hashtag
chesschamps and we do have some
suggestions that we really like and the
abaddon he says i don't know his name
but i have a feeling that this football
player could be good
and uh look at those skills then we have
it
who says we are not even allowed to
question the fact that bruce lee would
be the best chess player
only chuck norris is now interestingly
enough that's actually the
nickname that the russian team players
gave one of their teammates vladislav
artemyev
they were like he's too good he just
kills everyone and
uh finally we also liked paul cesan who
says
famous athlete that can be a great chess
player say no more
pictured below on manny pacquiao and
billiards legend efren
reyes so manny of course being a
world-class boxer and
uh yeah look at him he's actually
playing your opening david he's playing
the
hippo oh oh wow nicely spotted he's my
new favorite player
yes uh yeah yeah that's a very
poisonous opening there yeah yeah
exactly and uh yeah tweet your answers
to
using the hashtag chess champs and one
lucky winner will win
an air things device which monitors the
quality of air in your room
all right well we did see our reporter
oscar
doing the interview with magnus there
and we are
looking for more reporters to join our
team look at this
we are looking for tv reporters to join
our show
one in asia one in europe and one in
america
you will travel your continent doing
interviews with the players and will
join us
live to report from chess related events
do you
enjoy the thrill of being live on camera
can you
find the interesting stories and share
them with a global
audience send us some examples of your
work
and a screen test to tv casting at
playmagnets.com
we're so excited to expand our team and
hopefully getting some great reporters
to join us
to travel around in asia in europe and
in on the american continent
talking to the players and joining us
live in the show
all right well uh it's getting close the
third game in
the final between magnus carlsen and
wesley so if magnus crossing wins this
game
the first match will be over he will be
up by one point it's getting exciting
uh we're gonna take a little breather
before it all starts
our friend david howell and ivanka has
to you know save their voices a little
bit so we're gonna
see another video of david teaching us
some chess and it is another super
exciting one because it's called
the game of the century
[Music]
the champions chester logo is actually
based on a very famous game
it was a game between donald byrne and
bobby fisher
at the time fisher was only 13 years old
as well
and with the black pieces in this game
he created a masterpiece
he sacrificed his queen he confused his
opponent and he went on the attack
and we now call it the game of the
century
this is the position just before fischer
moved in for the kill
white is up by a queen but the white
king
is defenseless it doesn't have any
defensive pieces around it
therefore black bobby fischer decided it
was time to move into the kill
he gave a check with his bishop
attacking the white king
there's no way white can block and
white's king cannot move
to this side because the square is
controlled by the black knight
therefore white's king had to move
towards the black rook
fischer gave another check with his
other bishop this time attacking the
white king
again the king has to move towards the
black rook
now black decided to use his final piece
in the attack
the black knight came to check the white
king
white's king still cannot move away
because it is controlled by the bishops
therefore white's king had to move
towards the corner
black now decided to give a check with
his knight
the king moved across there's two
possible checkmates here that can use
his bishop to checkmate the white king
but instead bobby fischer used his rook
this rook is defended by the black
bishop
it attacks the white king and white's
king is trapped it cannot move to either
side
because the knight controls those two
squares a really stunning checkmate the
game of the century
and the perfect choice for the
champion's chest or logo
[Music]
yeah we actually have to mention the the
logo that we have that you see in on the
front of the table here is uh no
that's not it actually it is the logo
for the meltwater champions
or the purple one that is that exact
game game of the century i mean
that is that is huge to have played the
game of the century do you think we'll
ever
see a better game than this it's gonna
be hard to beat that one bobby fischer
at the time he was 13 years old against
one of the best players in his country
and i mean it was fireworks from the
start he was freestyling
sacrificing her queen sacrificing most
of his pieces and um we saw at the end
there i mean finishing off with
precision one of the best players in
history and i think
it's going to take a lot to match that
this century at least so even if that
last game we had in the final here you
might go was super exciting and a crazy
opening by wesley so
it's not quite game of the century i
guess not quite
not quite you know you need to see some
queen sacrifices you need to see
something that's going to leave you like
wow i did not expect that but you know
that one's still
brilliant yeah all right uh we are
heading into game three in the final
between wesley so and magnus carlson
these are the results after two games a
draw in the first one magnus carlsen
winning
this last one and we also see timora
jabo is up by one point
in the fight for the third place in the
tournament and we are heading into
game three between magnus carlsen and
wesley so wesley so
stretching it out here getting ready for
a game he needs at least a draw
preferably a win here to get back in
magnus carlsen with the white pieces
made his move that's right and magnus
carson he's switching it up he's trying
to keep wesley so guessing
in the first game of today magnus carson
pushed his queen's pawn on the first
move this time he's pushed his king's
pawn forward
and we see a very solid opening called
the berlin defense
um this one is rock solid lots of trades
already a set of pawns have left the
board a set of knights have left the
board um white's rook retreating now
black's offering a trade of rooks the
problem with this opening is it's known
to be extremely drawish
magnus carson tends to use it when he's
but he's happy to make a draw rooks have
left the board now
white darting forward with the bishop um
i've seen this position before
by both players um didn't you use this
uh position
this exact position to draw against
alpha zero that's right i
used this exact position with white to
make a draw against alpha zero the
strongest uh entity out there um
the artificial intelligence program um
so we might see the bishops leave the
board
magnus he's heading for straight for the
draw he i expect to see a draw within a
few moves
um he now retreats his knight we'll see
black
offer a trade of rooks rooks will leave
the board and it's only going to be
queen and knight against queen and
knight magnus carson
he i mean he's the world champion he
shocks us all the time i thought he'd
try and press forward with the white
pieces right
i'm surprised by this especially by the
fact that okay the repetition is now
coming
thick and fast um the players repeat the
same position three times and the game
is a draw
blink and you missed it how many minutes
did i last
maybe one okay i'm surprised
it's uh not often we see this for magnus
carlsen but he has played with the white
pieces
a draw after 29 moves about 60 seconds
um and that means he is still up by one
point
he only needs a draw in that last game
to be the winner of day one
but wesley saw will have the white
pieces in that last game
and he needs to win that wow and now he
has some time to
prepare yeah sure very short game i mean
it's a shocking stuff to be honest i
mean very surprising
um from magnus carson you can kind of
understand his decision he's now one
game closer to winning today's first
match of the final but from wesley so
he's gambled everything on winning the
next game with the white pieces it's uh
risky strategy from wesley so
um only one game now left he's going to
have to throw everything at the world
champion he cannot afford a repeat
of anything like that last game so you
guys announced it right away when they
started after just a few minutes oh wow
what a drawish game this is probably
going to be a draw how could we see that
it was
so so close to a drop yeah so the game
it started
i mean it started with the berlin
defense black's most solid opening
um out there pretty much it was first
popularized
years and years ago but it was brought
back to worldwide attention by vladimir
kramnik when he deposed
gary kasparov from the uh from the world
title vladimir using this opening to
frustrate kasparov
um with the black pieces making so many
draws just
casper of unable to crack this opening
with the white pieces and we saw
okay the trade started happening here a
set of brooks leaves the board
a few moves later a set of bishops
leaves the board as well
bishops are traded on this turn and
again
bishop's leaving the board now there's
another set of bishops leave the board
and
this moment rook's leaving the ward as
well um it became clear that
with neither side having real weaknesses
both sides with
a queen and knight each um it's
completely level and the reason this
game was a draw is because white creates
a threat
against the knight black defends against
it white creates another threat against
this pawn
black defends and this situation went on
three times
not much to do with black you just have
to react to your opponent's moves and
magnus carson he was the one who forced
the draw
and he's gambling on the fact he will
draw and hold
the next game with black is this very
unlike magnus crossing mic or is it
actually very smart
sensible play from him well with the
tournament situation of course
yes i mean i i must admit i'm a bit
hesitant about this approach because you
know magnus had the white pieces the
white pieces
traditionally gives you the advantage we
saw
how dangerous wesley so was in the
second game
with the white pieces he really had
magnus
carlsen on the ropes i don't know
i i think it's a little bit of a gamble
so we'll see
i mean it's very natural for wesley so
to actually take the draw
because he's playing with the black
pieces and he can basically
try as hard as he can with the white
pieces and uh we'll
we'll have to see a battle there it's
going to be exciting the last game of
today in the final between magnus
carlsen and wesley so wesley
has to win that game it's going to be
exciting and it's starting in
about 10 minutes now we are talking also
about other sports and football in
particular
today magnus carlsen is setting up his
fantasy
chess team based on the game fantasy
premier league fantasy football but it
is a field
of chess players we've seen his
defenders we've seen his
midfielders and now it's time to see the
goal scorer is who does magnus carlsen
want on top
as attackers let's see welcome to
[Music]
welcome to a skill asking
magnus we know you're a big fan of the
fantasy premier league football we have
a challenge for you
we want you to combine your love for uh
chess
with your interest for fantasy we have
paul murphy okay he will be attacker he
was definitely
of ahead of his time he was good both
uh positionally um better than his
contemporaries as well as
uh being a romantic player with uh with
a great tactical eye
so he will be um he will be on the wing
as a central striker
we will have uh we will have kasparov
so he will be your number nine he is
just an absolute
absolute menace if you compare him to
like a top
quality number nine striker in football
history
who would that be i think he's a little
bit like
um modern ronaldo to be to be honest
like
absolutely professional
ruthless and uh
unstoppable and then we will have
uh fisher as well you can certainly get
into the box
and uh uh he definitely cannot be left
out of the team that's a fierce uh
attack i must say
uh morphy cosplato and fisher i don't
want to be
to be playing in defense versus these
guys we need a manager as well
that would probably have to be uh
courtney
who would be constantly
barking directions at
the team and uh
be disgusted with uh with every move
that's a great attacking and trio and
and with you and karpov in midfield i'm
sure they will get plenty of balls
to work with as well i mean what a team
thank you
catch you later
[Music]
ah oscar said it what a team of
chessberries uh there we have it the
fancy chessy for magnus carlsen and we
are now joined
by ginger gm simon williams in england
i mean the football country of england
simon what do you think of magnus's
fantasy chess team
is pretty strong team that one um i
don't think he could get a stronger team
than he picked there and
some great players in in that lineup
definitely yeah 100
with it and if you were to exchange uh
one of the players with
david howell where would david howell be
on the field
wow dave is a very flexible player he
could be uh
up front he could be in the middle i'd
probably put him on the reserve bench
though but um no
only joking we put him in midfield we
put him in the center of the
center of the field i think i think i
would be left back
in the changing rooms
how about yourself simon where would you
if you had to be a player
or the manager which would you which
would you choose i think i i think i'd
certainly be in the changing rooms as
well
but if i if i had to be on the pitch i
think it would probably be
an attacker how are you
um in the stand
watching but okay okay i
if i was placed myself and probably
defender
all right well simon i i know there is a
premier league round going on in england
as well but do you think the drama there
can is
anything compared with the drama we've
seen so far in the final
not with this last game being a quick
draw but with that second game
yes absolutely fantastic second game we
had there and i'm sure we'll have a look
at it soon but
it was uh there's some very interesting
points there that wesley so
with the white pieces sacked his piece
but he was following
and i don't know if you're aware of this
his own course that he's just made for
chessable
so he's following he was following the
lines that he's he's just released
which i don't think magnus was aware of
so it's out in the public
place you notice courses there but then
he forgot his moves
so he got to he got to a certain point
he forgot it but
first of all round one and uh round one
we had
this position where magnus had the white
pieces uh
against wesley and and i actually fought
here that you know uh
magnus maybe could have pushed a little
bit more in trying to win this position
because
it's very symmetrical but he's got this
fantastic
night and that night is really nice you
can't really ever take that night off
because if you do take that knight
somehow let's say after the move played
which i think was g5
um then magnus can recapture with the c
pawn let's say
and he's got this strong pawn and his
rook is attacking
that guy there but i was i was surprised
that
very quickly after the move g5 played
wesley showed i think he'd be a defender
wesley he's clearly a brilliant defender
and he showed his power in defensive by
bringing the bishop back round
in actual fact magnus um not like not
like him which he normally does he
actually ended up defending this game
and trying to get a draw later on with
that bishop coming
to attack the pawn on c4 which is
surprising because i'm sure magnus is
still a little bit better
in this current position here and it was
a draw in this
new one but then we came to game two and
we had all the drama you're mentioning
that opening by wesley so
i'm gonna go straight into chess ball
after this actually and look at that
but uh eventually a blunder there but
you have chosen some moves is that
before or after that blunder with simon
i'm well i think the move was on about
move 20
21 21 22 so if we can bring up that
position
this is in the chesapore course so you
can if you want to play like wesley get
that course
chesapal doing great without opening
novelties and i
think it had caught magnus out by
surprise
and magnus now plays queen takes d4
which is actually a very
clever defensive move he realizes he's
got to give a piece back
and in this position wesley so now
deviates from his course
and he plays queen takes queen actually
in his course and the move he recommends
instead of queen tate's queen is bishop
c4 here
so it does show us that even these top
players they forget
they forget things so i'm like yes it's
not just me who forgets things these
guys forget things so
it's quite nice to know that but bishop
c4 is apparently the move to play
in the game after he took on d4 and
i think this is the very natural move
you take on d4
the knight recaptures you come in with a
check
this looks very tempting magnus played a
brilliant
idea he could move his king but he
blocks the check with his bishop
and the reason this is a clever idea is
it because he's giving a piece
back because now white takes that piece
lots of exchanges here
going on and the rook now takes so it's
like okay
white's now two pawns up but all of a
sudden look at those guys sleeping
in the corner of the board this rook
this knight and bishop they they haven't
moved at all
so magnus was able to get the initiative
and put the pressure now onto wesley
which ended in a brilliant win actually
for magnus there
yeah do you think simon it was sort of
do you think it was the nerves of the
final for
for wesley there because we're not used
to seeing in blunder or
did he simply fall into those mistakes
because he went into such a crazy
strange game actually i i think it was
it's strange i mean i think he just got
something mixed up i don't know what it
was because
normally top players they remember their
their preparation
and um it's very peculiar for him i
think he got tempted with that check
winning a piece but then only then did
he think oh maybe i've done something
wrong so it's a little bit like okay
sit on your hands they say to kids who
are playing chess don't
rush with your hands to go into the
first check sit on it and just consider
it a little bit more
and i think even that advice to wesley
there to sit on his hands would
have worked very well in that situation
yeah that's what you're saying as well
you want to
the trigger happy hand is that was that
a problem for for wesley here
yeah i think he he he didn't it wasn't
quite a trigger happy hand because he
didn't move
instantaneously that's the kind of
situation when you think of a move
and then you make it before before
you've even known what's happened and
you process the move
um here i just think he just saw one
possibility and was just seduced by
winning the extra material as simon says
yeah it looked like the right move just
the wrong order and um simon so after
that game where magnus carlton did come
out on top
then the quick draw the i mean the
lightning fast draw what did you make of
that one
i was a little bit of a shock because i
thought i'm gonna have a bit more time
to prepare myself to come in the studio
and it's like
whoa the game's over right it's like oh
um i mean it's a little bit
disappointing because um
wesley now has to win the last round
then any quick draw is disappointing i
think it's understandable because
wesley figures okay i've got the black
pieces i'll take a draw and i'll
go all in in the last round but we never
like seeing quick draws do we
we want to we want to see a proper fight
yeah and we probably will in the last
one now and
finally as i'm in uh we have to give you
the quiz of the day we always do
we do so i hope this time you're
prepared simon so
we have a sporting theme in the studio
and so we are asking
everyone what famous athlete
would make the best chess player
what famous athletes okay um
i would go for well i don't know you
saying bolt is
springing to my mind cause that's a
popular choice so
it's a popular choice i mean i think
he'd be very strong
he's very confident he's also he doesn't
seem to get nervous
whenever you see usain bolt he's all
shaking hands with the people at the
side and i think
nerves is very important in a game of
chess and
he would rush through an attack very
well and he would also be good at doing
the
his final celebration at the end i think
that'd be quite appropriate in chess
tournament hall
so i'll go usain bolt good answer good
answer
and uh well simon thanks i love your
shirt by the way and
david stein all dressed up for the final
thank you for joining us simon
okay thank you so you can see and we're
gonna head straight
into that last game of the first match
in the final
it is wesley sona with the white pieces
he has to win this game he has to win
this game to tie the match
magnus carlsen only needs a draw or win
to be the winner
of first day in the final and we're
waiting for wesley
to make his first move with the white
pieces should we expect something
dramatic like in that
the second game yeah i think wesley so
as
simon mentioned he's done a huge amount
of work recently on his white openings
uh i know the first thing i'm going to
do when i get home is buy that chessball
course
and here we see wesley so he's just
gonna aim for something very similar
to his last white game to game two of
the final
um he's gonna aim for chaos basically he
needs that
we're not gonna see a repeat of that
last game quick draw all the pieces
hoovered off the board
early on we're gonna see wesley so go
all in uh
remember a draw is the same as a loss in
this game for wesley so and
okay magnus carson meanwhile does not
allow what wesley so did in that last
game
magnus carson is the first to deviate
it's still the italian game but no more
fried liver attacks
and here we see okay wesley so smiling
slightly
both players playing very fast this is
also a very fashionable
opening um one of my good friends one of
my compatriots
grandmaster gawain jones has been
playing this one for years he's beaten
me many times with this opening
from the white side and it's become
popular recently due to the efforts of
players such as levon oronian
who's championed this from the white
side as well both players
very well rehearsed white has an extra
central pawn but black
is super active black's king also
castled away to safety
before white's king has found safety
itself
black ahead in development whereas white
has an extra grip
on the center with that extra pawn and
yeah this one is in the balance so far
it does feel like it will come down to
maybe a battle of
opening preparation again is magnus
carson prepared for this
did he predict this in advance if not
then wesley so will have the advantage
at this early stage magnus carlson in
the move thinking
wesley so well um
it's the face of someone who knows he
has to win uh is it can magnus sort of
here just
force this into a draw is it looking
like that's what he's doing um he's
going to try magnus carson but the one
thing you notice is that all of the
pieces remain on the board
um for now at least there's only been
one set of pawns
been traded so far and magnus carson
bringing his night out
i actually recently watched a stream uh
by peter svidler
and he said this is black's best move
bringing the knight out he said it's
very easy to equalize here
you just need to know two or three key
details and magnus carson he's the world
champion
he tends to know his stuff he got caught
out in that last
um and that last game was black but
wesley started now smiling
why is he smiling ivanka is it because
he's happy with the way the opening went
is he always looking like he can't
remember his lines
i had that issue actually when i when i
wrote my book you know
maybe for the first month or so it was
like fresh in my mind
i i scored a few scalps and then as the
time drew on i began to forget more and
more of it and you kind of
yeah this kind of writing writing
something or producing a video course is
a little bit of a double-edged sword you
know you
you learn so much at the same time
there's so much information to process
that's impossible to remember everything
um yeah but i'm surprised actually that
the seconds of magnus haven't uh
haven't checked out the course yep
that's um
that would be like number one on the
priority right
yeah if you know who your opponent is in
advance and if you know that recently
they've just
released all their secrets they've
published a huge amount of material
um surely you should be looking for
holes in that material trying to
find positions where you think okay
they're not correct about their
evaluation of this position
but instead magnus carson went into that
kind of blind uh he just
um clearly his coaches hadn't thought of
checking out wesley's chestable course
meanwhile maybe wesley um i'm not sure
but maybe wesley suggested this
opening as well and this type of
position will magnus carlsen
uh be able to kind of freestyle again it
looks like maybe he's out of book right
now
he is unfamiliar with this exact
position that last move by wesley
slightly surprising
retreating the queen but then again at
least this is a different type of
position to the last game right
yeah where magnus he can just maneuver
he can trade some things
it's not do or die right now well in
fact this position has been played
before
it's been played five times so
yeah definitely in the realms of not
mainstream
yeah not mainstream and um just over the
last three moves we saw
three sets of minor pieces leave the
board so lots and lots of trades
suddenly
um magnus carson he's just trying to
clarify the situation
we saw with the quick draw in the last
round magnus doesn't want any more
tension he's done with all the stress
and all the pressure he's just trying to
trade all the pieces off the board but
wesley so he's keeping queens for now
and queen and knight tend to work a bit
better than queen and bishop if it
becomes
a position where one side can attack um
wesley pushing all those pawns in the
center white has more central pawns than
black does
would you prefer your anchor well i i'm
gonna go for
wesley i mean let's just forget the the
white position but in terms of the
players i'm gonna go for wesley because
look at him
he has started well he's got more time
than he started basically two and a half
minutes two and a half minutes more and
he's just
whizzing out the moves so definitely he
seems to believe that white is better so
therefore okay i'm going to choose white
yeah i mean gaining almost two and a
half minutes on the clock it means that
out of the 20 moves played so far
15 of those came instantly from wesley
to gain those extra 10 seconds after
every move
and that's how confident he's feeling he
has definitely done his research he's
done his homework
wesley the ultimate professional
meanwhile magnus carlsen
maybe just kind of winging it in a way
um
but then again he's got a super solid
position and as black here
there's a few choices black can clarify
the tension by capturing this pawn
but maybe he doesn't want to allow any
checks right now
the other move that i'm very attracted
to is capturing this pawn in the center
because when white recaptures with his
knight yes the white knight is strong
but later on in the game maybe after a
trade of rooks um a bit later black can
at least
start to kick away this night or trade
off more pieces the more pieces
disappearing from the board the easier
it will become to draw i'd be tempted
actually to play this right now
yeah with black just get rid of your
opponent's strong knight um in the
middle of the board
and magnus he's got those draw odds um
he can bully wesley in a way just say
okay any trades
are going to help me i'm going to start
kicking back your pieces i think this
would be
very sensible my magnus yeah i agree
with you i i do quite like pawn takes
pawn but at the same time it's kind of
clarifying what white should be doing
um so this magnus could try to kind of
put pressure on the center immediately
and say okay i i don't want to
let you have a knight there in the
center i don't want you to get that free
move
maybe i too can uh put pressure by
retrieving the bishop now
okay so black could also retreat the
bishop first eyeing up this pawn in two
different ways
and trying to force white to clarify the
the central tension by taking this pawn
and then maybe stepping forward with the
rook and um yeah again it looks like
very very solid sensible play by both
sides um lots of choice by magnus
carlsen
um yeah i like both of those options
just either taking first and then
reacting
um to that strong knight or just not
even allowing a strong knight to appear
back um other moves might include maybe
just improving the queen slightly to one
of these two squares
that's why magnus cast and he's been
thinking almost three minutes because
yeah he has choice it's very pleasant
lots of tension has been clarified
already
and lots of trades have happened so um
why not
start to think now the opening is over
and uh maybe try and get wesley out of
his comfort zone because wesley
the longer it goes on while he's
familiar with the position we've seen
that can
be very dangerous yeah okay so magnus
has retreated the position
so i mean it's kind of interesting kind
of like stylistic approach to this game
you know either you're going to clarify
the center simplify basically or you're
just going to say no i like it
i like it like that and just keep
mounting the pressure but
you know wesley is unfazed and this is
disconcerting because you come up with a
move you spend three minutes thinking
and they're like
now he's out of it yeah and look wesley
goes
no wesley says no i'm gonna play again
instantly um spending almost no time on
that last move and look at white spawns
in the middle now um
if white is able to step another pawn
into the middle he'll actually have four
pawns
in the center of the board at the same
time and um that's
a very very rare scenario so magnus
carlton he needs to recapture the pawn
that's just moved
he's got two ways to do that with the
queen with the pawn usually you'd want
to capture with the pawn but then black
would give himself an isolated pawn so
the queen does step forward
uh black's queen now very actively plays
but can we kick that queen away ivanka
push the pawn forward attacking that
queen um it looks like a very easy
natural move here from
wesley so but there's choice again and
uh
yeah i'm surprised one thing i'm
surprised by at least is the computer
evaluation the bar says that white has a
quite a decent advantage right now but
on the board um
it's level material everything seems
roughly balanced
that says to me that white maybe has
something a bit immediate but
it's not clear exactly what right now
computers do tend to value
central pawns a lot higher than
sideborns than flank pawns so
maybe that's the reason but wesley so he
needs to find a way to
kind of unsettle the world champion very
quickly over the next few moves
before the queen's come off before black
is somehow able to activate all his
pieces the black rook as well in the top
left-hand corner and not
really playing so um we're so huge
advantage on the clock but
the board needs to be he needs to be
accurate he needs to be precise here um
definitely i mean i would also be
tempted like david said to push my pawn
forward
and then uh and then capture a pawn so
uh
yeah just uh just quite pleasant for
white
yeah um definitely i mean who would you
prefer here ivanka whose position at
least
which one do you think is easier to play
white white yeah
yeah with white you have some very easy
plans at least and
yeah if we bring up the board maybe the
move we're looking for here uh
for wesley so there's two main options
there's tension against your pawn in the
center so you could take this pawn
and next move you could start to push
forward in the center creating a very
nice kind of barrier
controlling lots of squares attacking
the black queen as well or
you could start this way first you could
kick the black queen away first
force this queen to retreat somewhere
and then take the pawn
and now try and make use of these pawns
by maybe starting an attack
i'm not sure exactly how maybe push the
pawn forward or maybe activate the rook
but okay wesley does it another way yeah
he takes your first approach he
takes the pawn and after we
i mean black has to play rook takes pawn
no one is going to take with the pawn
are they you don't open up your king
no exactly so i mean rook takes pawn and
then we probably
expecting uh wesley to march forward
with the pawns
look at those two beauties in the center
they control so many squares there's
like four squares
and uh white queen just gets well the
black queen sorry gets just
kicked about and uh where do you put it
as well you've got to be careful if you
if you step to the wrong square you
might get attacked along this diagonal
white has a double
yeah double attack right now um there's
a trap there but
yeah if you step to the wrong square as
well you might get kicked away by the
exactly and just have to point out that
white's queen
is uh on a square that we quite kind of
call goldilocks
and uh it wasn't me who came up with the
term so don't blame me it was
i'm going to blame english grand master
neil mcdonald is from his book
and he kind of calls this particular
square
the perfect position for the queen
because the queen can move to the left
she can move to the right she can move
forward she can move
both sides of the board forward you know
she just has complete flexibility
and so you really do want your yeah
there you can look at that
look at her she's so powerful and this
is such an important thing to notice and
actually if
if you observe computers play they often
do
ridiculous things to get their queen on
that square
so yeah it's it's just a point to
mention
that trouble is brewing yeah it does
look like trouble is brewing that's why
magnus carson suddenly slowed down
um his move in the current position is
so obvious i mean
as ivanka mentions no one in their right
mind after pawn takes born would ever
dream of capturing the other way with
their pawn because suddenly the black
king is
very open there's suddenly more open
lines towards it so
why not just capture with the rook and
then start to think um it's very odd
that magnus
miss carson would spend two minutes on
pretty much an obvious forced move
um the world champion must be looking
ahead he's wondering not what to do in
the current position but he's wondering
what to do next move after white kicks
the queen away
um suddenly realizing that black is
maybe in a tiny little bit of trouble
uh because of white's strong center and
the golden locks queen what the computer
is saying and that is
definitely trouble for magnus girls okay
and
magnus carson plays the move that we
thought uh
no way you said a chess player would
never play that move david
why is magnus cousin playing that move
um
i i just lost for words um
he's just opened up his own king he's
isolated his own pawns look at the black
pawns on the right side there
they're completely isolated there's so
many bad squares
kind of weak squares around the black
king look at magnus's face as well he
just grimaced
he did not look happy he knows that's an
ugly move um he didn't play that move
because he lacks understanding or
anything he played it because he thought
the alternative
alternatives were worse he thought after
taking with the rook
maybe in that variation we showed after
white kicks the queen away maybe he
thought
black simply has no good squares for the
queen um but now white's position
and then we see it again magnus carson
not looking happy but white's position
is super pleasant
if white can somehow coordinate his
queen with the knight then white will be
in complete control scary co2 levels for
wesley solar 666.
you're insinuating nothing
i just noticed three three six numbers
there
so let's not talk about that um
yeah i guess uh they're better co2
levels than magnus castle no
magnus carlsen's co2 levels slightly
higher humidity still
pretty much the same the whole
tournament yeah but uh have you seen
that the co2 levels are creeping up and
up
so the longer the day goes on exactly
yeah maybe that's why magnus carson took
that quick draw in the last game because
he wanted to
reduce the effects of the co2 levels but
okay meanwhile wesley so pushes forward
with the pawn
this was the move we liked um if black
had captured with the rook
on the last turn kicking away the black
queen but this time i'm not so sure it
was necessary
um white had white had plenty of other
options
um i would have gone straight to try and
improve my pieces to
get to watching black king i would have
i would have put my
knight on the edge and
taken some control on the squares um
yeah knights don't really belong on the
edge but
for here i would have made an exception
okay so the queen has retreated
is there anything well now we are
looking at ways
for wesley so to start making use of
that open king
is there any kind of point of attack can
the knight now relocate to the edge of
the board and
jump in to yeah that is the route that i
want to take i want to put a knight
on that beautiful beautiful square that
david is highlighting
let's just look at it can never be
chased away and i can just sit there
proudly and say my life
is done because i got my night there
look at this night you can just never
get rid of it for the rest of the game
it's on an outpost
it's anchored by a pawn it's supported
by a rook and
bobby fischer and gary kasparov they
have gone on record saying as soon as
you get to a knight
to the square f5 it's worth at least a
pawn
and i think gary kasparov said uh if he
gets a knight two five he's confident
he'll give
checkmate um and yeah simply black's
king now is never gonna feel completely
safe
um the knight also it has attacking
ideas it controls a lot of squares it
also has defensive ideas it controls
and supports its central pawn so this is
the ideal square for white tonight
um i would be shocked if magnu if wesley
so doesn't play his knight to the edge
of the board either now or the next
couple of moves
the only thing he might be looking out
for is that if black steps forward with
the queen
suddenly there's a bit of an ominous
threat down here
um black's queen and bishop lining up
together i think this is
kind of you can ignore it in a way yeah
i was gonna say just put your knight
there
in the center attack the queen and just
say come on come on come on get me
and so when the queen comes to give
check the king will go fine
no problem step forward and then your
queen is trapped
trapped edge on the board yeah she has
to give a check
doesn't she she has to give a check and
now white can either trade queens
or you can just sidestep with your king
and somebody's queen it is tempting
isn't it a sidestep
normally this is like comes with a
safety warning you do not put your king
in the center
but you know look at black's pieces they
just cannot attack this king
and it's more the problem of uh black's
king that is totally totally abandoned
yeah i think if wesley so plays this
move if he brings his knight to the
edges board
relocating it to this square wesley so
i'd be shocked if he doesn't win the
game actually because the knight is just
simply going to be so good once it gets
there
okay he first brings his rook to the
center of the board but
um this idea is not going to run away
for the next few moves it will still
still be there um yeah i'm surprised
wesley so
just improve the rook first i thought
it's maybe more urgent to bring the
knight to this
uh that beautiful outpost yeah i agree
with you david i mean i
well my problem is that i'm quite a
direct player you know once i see a plan
i want to
implement it get going and uh
here well wesley has taken a little bit
more subtle approach
and uh developed the rook to the center
but you know magnus follow suite
and uh do it again yeah time to do it
again bring the knight to the edge of
the board
bring it to this key square and if you
do it wesley
you're going to be in charge your knight
is going to dominate the opponent's
pieces
um but i don't unders i don't really see
what else there is to do for white so
wesley okay he plays yeah
we got the knight to the edge and now
it's headed to greener pasture
pastures yeah if black's king sidesteps
for example this knight
is going to control everything um white
can play around it he's going to start
bringing maybe his queen round to the
side
to attack black's king um later on he's
gonna
maybe uh bring his queen to the other
side he this is the goldilocks queen it
can play on any side of the board but
the knight
holds everything together it attacks and
it defends um
it's dominant position for and there's
nothing magnus can do okay he moves his
king
he does move his king yeah wesley will
plant his knight on that square magnus
meanwhile he'll try and bring his rook
across maybe he'll launch a
counter-attack
he'll try to get the white king but the
problem is it takes so long to do this
you bring a rook across
maybe white's king or sidestep it takes
so long to build this kind of double
rook idea
uh but then once you finally achieve it
white will just defend this pawn and say
okay
you've got nothing to do next um yeah
magnus
he's leaning back but i think he'll
start to realize soon that he's in
trouble
um at least long-term strategic trouble
he's not going to get checkmated any
time soon
um with black you still you're vaguely
solid
um solid in the kind of the loosest
extent of the word
but yeah white knight is simply the best
piece on the board by a long long way
yeah so we're expecting magnus to try to
generate some play
by moving his rook one square to the
right
and uh trying to i kind of like bluff
wesley because i i mean this is the kind
of situation where
you try to create ghosts so that your
opponent
panics and starts reacting to them
unnecessarily and
if this happens then magnus gets some
chance to counter-attack because it's
not necessarily the most accurate move
but uh what is uh wesley's plan of
attack though
i mean we've done everything nicely the
knight is on is amazing square
the rooks are on open lines the two
pawns are
like well they're standing proud
what next yep that's a good question
what next and
um wesley he'll try and make all the
useful i mean there's still plenty of
useful moves remaining at least he'll
make all those useful moves first
and then he'll decide how to attack what
i would be looking for for white i would
shift my
king to right to the corner um because
it's on a white square it always feels
safer on a white square when your
opponent has a dark squared bishop
meanwhile i'd maybe start to try and
attack black's pawns up there on the
left side um
they're on open lines they're going to
be easy targets for the white rooks
uh maybe i'd push my own pawn there on
the left side just trying to gain some
space on both sides of the board
um wesley shaking his head but i don't
think he's too worried he's just
maybe he's just calculating um yeah when
the time is right then i would try to
improve the white rooks
i'd look for targets at the moment they
look nice and pretty on semi-open lines
but they're not really attacking
anything
um also that goldilocks queen
when the time is right you decide do you
shift it to the left do you shift to the
right
um plenty of options black just has no
plan that's that's uh
why i think and magnus is down to seven
minutes on the clock now
as he makes his move well you say magnus
uh
has no plan well he's he's certainly
given uh wesley a plan
which is which is now he has a protected
past pawn
way hey hey you know great stuff but
okay there was a consequence and the
bishop has now improved itself
yeah um if we bring up the analysis
board a couple of things have changed on
the last couple of
on the last two turns um in this
position magnus pushing a pawn forward
um this pawn cannot be captured because
then your queen would fall
behind and this queen supported by a
rook black would emerge with an extra
rook so that's why
wesley was obliged to step forward with
his own pawn and
yes he's created a perfect passport now
in any end game with the queens off the
board white would be winning because
this pawn
protected is simply going to rush down
to the end of the board it's got no
rival but the consequence
was that with this pawn push um black
has now got a great square for his
bishop
this bishop on an outpost um as well the
thing is this bishop is
hitting thin air right now it's not
really attacking too much so the knight
still dominates it
but um white's pawn for now takes a long
time to get running it's blockaded
by the black queen maybe magnus carson's
idea is to push his own pawns he does
have this three versus one advantage now
on this left side so both sides have
ideas um
will wesley's central pawn and knight
combo become stronger or will
magnus carlsen's pawn advantage on this
left flank become
the dominant factor still in the balance
despite the fact that long term
it's all going to be white that's why
the computer lines loves white's
position right now because it sees
so far into the future it sees okay um
black's pawns just
take too long to get running um but okay
wesley still
questions questions because the position
could easily turn you know yeah white
has amazing
porn amazing night but you know there
are some trumps in black's position
i can see a scenario where if uh
wesley doesn't do anything that black
starts
running like crazy with those pawns on
the left side
just pushing them and causing all sorts
of problems
so tense yeah so tense and
uh wesley just kills any possibility of
that he kind of sees the danger and he's
like nope
not even gonna have not even gonna worry
about it i'm gonna stop you before those
pawns even get motoring
and uh yeah it's annoying when your
opponent does that
when they see your plans yeah when they
see it and they're kind of like it's
like most rude
rude indeed and now look at what wesley
is doing he's brought his rook across
controlling one black pawn now he's
blockaded another black pawn with his
own queen
queen's actually the worst blockaders
but wesley for now
is saying okay my queen is on a light
square you can never kick it away i'm
going to improve the rest of my pieces
first
but the most important thing the most
urgent issue is to stop your black pawns
advancing and
it is awkward for magnus carson now to
find a new plan
he's tried to get his pawns running
that's been stopped um he does
shift his rook across one square a bit
of an odd move there
that rook is actually blocked by black's
bishop which is on its perfect square so
the black bishop doesn't really want to
move
meanwhile wesley i mean look at every
one of white's pawns and
pieces are all on white squares this is
ideal strategy
um from wesley so none of them can be a
target now for black's bishop
um wesley he's gonna slowly when he's
ready start advancing his pawn on the
left there
to try and undermine um black's pawn
majority on that left flank
yawning here wesley so in a situation
where
it's looking very good for him i mean
he's improving
every single move he's making and every
single move magnus is making
yeah yeah but he did show some signs of
tiredness there did you just
catch a glimpse of it because he seemed
to be squeezing his eyes together and
shaking his head
like saying wake up but uh his position
is more than good enough
yeah his position on the board is very
good the reason he shook his head is
probably because he's yawning and not
feeling super fresh
um but i mean on the board at least
white has a clear plan
what's black doing magnus carson i mean
he's not only four minutes down on the
clock but
he's also got an uphill struggle just to
find an idea for black a productive idea
yeah i i have an idea i have an idea
because because black's rooks are really
bad so let's just move them to an open
line
uh this one yeah just move it to an open
line he's not going to do this ivanka
because
last move if you look at it he's just
moved his rook across oh yes
he can move it again yes maybe he should
maybe you're right
yeah that would mean he's accepting the
fact he made a mistake on his last time
bringing his rook the wrong way
now having to shift it the uh back but
okay for example if i start pushing
forward on myself
what will you do well david we don't
have time for that because we do have a
really interesting move that he's played
he's moved the bishop this was his
sneaky idea
and uh never underestimate magnus
carlsen setting those traps
yeah but this was ignored so white could
snack on this bishop but suddenly
black's rook would drop down taking a
pawn
and creating a pin white's knight cannot
move and next move will drop
so this was avoided by wesley so in this
position after what
black's move he brought his rook up and
magnus carson sacrificed a rook
giving up his rook for a pawn and now
after rook takes rook queen takes knight
we're seeing um black suddenly trying to
create a pin these two rooks on the same
diagonal
i'm surprised by this though i think
wesley so he'll simply guard
his rooks um he'll double up these rooks
yes white's pawns have suddenly
disappeared the strong knight has
disappeared
but versus bishop normally a huge
advantage
um i think magnus carlsen he had to do
this so simply nothing else to do
and once wesley brings his rook across
maybe we'll see the black bishop
block these rooks um i mean
white is completely in in control here
but
there's no immediate winning planet and
magnus only needs a draw here
dora is enough to be the winner of the
first match
is that what he's playing for now just
trying to get rid of some pieces
and and getting into a more jewish
situation yeah
his rooks were so bad that he decided
okay fine
i'm just gonna sacrifice one of my rooks
for the night because that night was
just
awesome because uh you the bishop and
the queen and the rook can
work super well on dark squares but uh i
have to say
i'm not it might have been uh done by
desperation but i'm not a big fan of
this sacrifice
um yeah i mean i i mean i would have
waited
a little bit more i think it was pure
desperation yeah i mean there was just
nothing else to do white's knight was
too strong
i mean not only were the black rooks
blocked in but white's knight
had to just be eliminated from the board
so even at the cost of a rook
it was more important to get rid of
white's knight and wesley so doing the
right thing
lining up his rooks together rooks are
great when they're doubled up on open
lines like that
i think magnus he has to simply block
those rooks with his bishop
um otherwise there's gonna be trouble
white's rook threatening to jump up to
the top of the wood
attacking black's king yeah shall we
show the danger if
uh black gets greedy let's do it david
if black gets greedy and for example
takes this pawn with his queen
this would be a huge mistake um white
will not allow the
queen trade he'll drop his rook to the
top of the board giving check
and okay for example if black takes this
rook now the uh protection of the black
queen has disappeared and we will simply
win a queen at the end of the line
if black takes the other way ivanka if
he takes with the rook
looks equally bad right it looks
terrible the black king is now forced
out out into the open and look at this
the king will not survive for long
um it's going to get checked everywhere
and the rook's kind of creating this
cutting motion and at the end maybe
white would just drop his queen back and
keep those checks coming david yeah
that's coming exactly
and uh absolutely horrible horrible
situation
you cannot survive the onslaught when
it's two rooks
and a queen you know a queen or
basically there are a few rules on thumb
when a queen
is by herself you can perhaps you can
probably survive but the queen
and a rook are coming at your king and
your king is totally unguarded
forget it it's not going to happen uh if
it's queen and knight that's also bad
a queen and bishop if the bishop and the
queen are working on on different
diagonals
oh game over so i mean at all stages you
need to protect your king basically
yeah and the best way to protect the
king is for black i mean as we mentioned
a moment ago for black to
drop his bishop back and block the white
rooks wow
knight has gone away with fire um
no this is unbelievable look at the
computer it sees a win for white
immediately pretty much
um okay let's well let's run through
those lines again
actually white has a winning move right
now there's an even better move bring
the rook up to the top
check is good it's probably winning but
there's an even better move right now
um yeah if we bring up the analysis
board wesley is going to have a thing if
white finds this move bringing the rook
not up to the top of the board which is
tempting
but if you bring it across two squares
trapping the black king cutting off the
escape squares
the black king has no squares to run
away to now magnus carson will just
resign he's completely lost
the threat is to bring the rook up
checkmate the only way to stop this is
to bring your own rook back but suddenly
the white queen joins the attack
and this is going to be checkmate the
black king is just trapped magnus is
completely lost if
wesley so finds this move um sorry
bringing the rook across two squares
this is the winning move
um trap the king truck trap the king so
when you go when you go
king hunting you can either check the
king or trap the king and here it's
trapped the king
unbelievable move okay so thinking for a
minute here now wesley so
is he seeing this move that will end the
game
and uh that will give him a tie
in the final in the match and wow the
fact that wesley so has stopped
to think means he's looking for he's
looking for it
the most natural human move the instinct
would have said look for checks first
drop your rook up to the top of the
board giving check that's promising but
not immediately winning the game would
go on and if we so does manage to step
away from the temptation of giving a
check if he just shuffles his rook
across the black king is trapped
and the game is pretty much over the
only way for black to survive is to give
up the queen
wow this is so tense well wesley's so
fined
this move he's got a lot of time on the
clock compared to minus carlson
this is the movie needs to fight would
you think david we're on tentacooks here
do you think wesley is going to find it
i think he's going to find it he's spent
enough time now to be looking deeply
into the position
um no kind of magnet seeing it though he
he
usually reacts when he has blundered or
done some mistakes
he has not reacted at all i realized i
don't think he realizes i think they're
just working through the checks the
thing is though
the check is the most logical move you
know is the move that our eyes were
immediately drawn to
because it's like you get going with
especially with two rooks
um but wesley does have the time to
figure it out
and the move actually this rook move
that david points out that is going to
be the killer blow is actually something
that we should have on the list because
it threatens checkmate
so it should be there yep so in the
current position
wesley he's looking at these checks he's
looking at check um
he's looking at another check he's
looking at another check and all these
checks because it's very natural
check check check it forces your
opponent's moves but sometimes the list
goes
checks if those don't work then you look
for captures there are no obvious
captures here then you look for threats
so it's not the first thing on his list
to calculate that is the only thing
really
kind of stopping him right now um but
he's deciding between these two moves
and
um this move is not a hundred percent
obvious but if he finds it he's gonna
win
let's look at wesley there on the camera
he was dancing with his head
he's calculated he found it okay and
wow look magnus is not reacting at all
his face is completely the same
okay he yeah he's trying to keep a poker
face but look we're seeing a series of
tracks
white's queen dropping back an amazing
idea look at this white's last move
bringing the queen back and now the
queen is simply going to enter the game
and checkmate
magnus carlsen leaning back i think we
have to bring the players cameras up
because
this idea the queen jumping into the
game checkmate is unstoppable
black's king has no defenders it's
doomed um
the bar is saying 100 certainty that uh
wesley so will win this
yep we're waiting for minecraft to just
give up now yeah this face is uh i mean
that queen move is just unstoppable and
there's uh i missed it and he resigns
and fits in there for wesley so
he had to win this game to tie the the
first match in the final he
did it with amazing play it is a
bad loss for magnus crossing in the last
game but it's no crisis
because it means they are tied after the
first day of finals magnus carlson's
sitting there
now looking over this is that what he's
doing david yeah for sure i think he'll
just be confused magnus carson where all
went wrong
the opening wasn't the best he's ever
had the middle game started to turn
against him he gave
his opponent wesley so a strong night
and then just when it looked like he was
fighting back he got rid of that knight
suddenly he blundered and ah magnus just
forgetting about king safety again we've
seen it against dubov and vachelagrav
he's underestimating the opponent's
attacks
um yeah i mean wow wesley so to fight
back
it's mightily impressive um he was
uh he wasn't too angry yesterday after a
little bit of a bad day losing a few
games to maximum vagielagrave
because it was maxim who played
fantastically is is this the
situation today as well with wesley so
simply playing fantastic chess in this
last game yeah definitely um magnus
he'll be annoyed that he missed that
idea but at the same time he'll know his
wesley played a masterpiece yeah well he
magnus was in trouble from the opening
and there really
wasn't so much that magnus can do and
magnus himself said it yesterday against
maxine vasily graf
he couldn't solve the problems that maxi
imposed him and it's exactly the same
situation
here against wesley and i think that he
will be regretting that very quick draw
that he took
in the game three well david it was a
dramatic game this last one
uh it exploded at some point so where
did magnus girls lose this game
yeah so it actually came very close to
the end we'd actually
studied this position we'd gone into a
bit of detail here and we thought black
had to
look after his king safety he has to
stop white's rooks
from causing havoc along the back ranks
and in this position we thought
okay there's nothing to do you have to
drop your bishop back
block these white rooks and the game
goes on white is still in charge but
black has decent chances
to just create a fortress to hold the
fort and instead magnus carson
maybe missing that idea took this pawn
just trying to get a bit greedy but at
the wrong moment
white's rook moved giving check giving
check would have been strong
but instead he brought his rook across
trapping and cutting off the black king
the black king can never escape now he's
completely cornered and
this threat is almost unstoppable
bringing the rook up to the top
he created in the end some space for his
king some breathing space magnus carson
but after a couple of checks
we saw that the black king was trapped
in the corner and this queen retreat
bring
bring the queen back re-routing her out
to give checkmate
it's just devastating if pawn takes rook
we will see checkmate
on the board the black king trapton yeah
genius idea by
wesley so fantastic bye wesley saw the
winner of the last game today and that
means that the final is all
tied they won one game each today magnus
carlsen
and wesley so so it is 1-1 after one day
in the final i think we do have the
results
as well to see what happened today with
the games
um wesley soh must be feeling
so happy right now being the winner of
that last game in a must-win
situation for him if that game had ended
in a
uh uh in a draw or a win for magnus
minus would be the winner of day two and
we do see
what has happened so far in the knockout
stage magnus carlsen and wesley so
advancing from quarter finals and then
semifinals they did reach
the final um where it is now
half a point for both of the players yep
there we have it
half a point four minus girls and half a
point for wesley so in
the final match um the first match
so everything will now be decided
tomorrow in match number two
what should we expect from that one
javanka i think we're going to see more
of the same
wesley sow has been incredibly well
prepared in the opening
you know he has been masterful and he
certainly had magnus carlsen on the back
foot
magnus needs to adapt to that and uh i
think we are going to see another
big slug slugfest and whatever happens
we will have a winner that is the beauty
of the knockout system
exactly and we are right now joined by
minus carlson uh
and your reaction magnus after that last
uh
last game uh no it was okay i made a
mistake pretty early on and then i just
had a very bad position
um i probably could have fought a little
bit better there
by not taking uh taking on d5 but it was
it was difficult
uh anyway i'm uh
i'm fairly happy with uh with the drone
today uh
so i'll just try and uh um
[Music]
push a little bit harder tomorrow there
was one move in that last game that i
noted
i think it was the 22nd move and david
howell our expert said
uh no way will magnus carlsen uh move
his pawn hair to take the white pawn
no chess player would ever do that and
then you did magnus
why why did you make that move uh
opening up for the king there
uh which one oh
i just thought uh rook f6 e4 was
very very bad so i thought
with the gf6 at least keep some
stability
uh no i mean i i just um
i miscalculated something something
before
uh that was uh that was a problem but
with the the way this game
ended then do you sort of regret going
into that very quick draw in in your
last white game no i was uh
i was knackered so i needed uh i needed
a
short game ah and okay so the second
game was
um a crazy game what did you think of
that opening that wesley so made there
i was kicking myself a little bit for
for allowing it because i was checking
this stuff
during vacancy but not um not today for
some reason
uh for whatever reason i thought he
would
go for the the quiet line so yeah that
was really uh
kind of stupid um magnus were you aware
that actually the position for 21 moves
it did follow
uh wesley so's chessable course oh now
if i'd been aware of that i wouldn't
have played it
will you be tempted to watch some of it
tonight maybe
maybe i'll make others do it
[Laughter]
well minus a final day of the final
tomorrow
you've had super good first days in the
knockout stage
now you're tied uh does that mean we'll
see a very aggressive magnus crossing on
the second day
uh i will uh i'll certainly be more
aggressive
with with white that's for sure and
magnus we've had a lot of fun in the
studio today because we've seen a few
videos
where you uh pick out your fantasy chess
teams what the
chess players you would have on your
fantasy team and wesley so
almost made it and with this play maybe
especially in the second game today
would you make maybe take him back in
uh i don't know yeah
i also have a question so we've been
asking our viewers
which famous athlete would be the best
chess player
so which one of the celebrities that
you've played has been surprisingly good
uh i don't know nobody has
blown me away after that
all right magnus um we're excited about
tomorrow hope you are as well
good luck thank you
all right and we are also joined by
wesley so the winner of the last game
today tying the final match
wesley you must be feeling very happy
right now
yeah hi kaya yeah i'm very thrilled
obviously uh to win on demand with the
white pieces
i mean white piece is much easier than
black but still it's a very difficult
thing to do
also so so i'm very pleased because uh
i was able to put pressure with the
white pieces and
actually we were following also this
line this also
from my for my chest above course in the
last game yes uh
we were so excited to see that you
brought your uh
uh opening preparations and and uh stuff
that you have done in those chesable
uh videos now didn't you think that
magnus maybe would have
looked at that i'm not
i i don't think so because uh i guess
my chanceable course is mostly geared
towards uh
lower rated players because there's a
lot a large public out there
uh i don't expect world champions to be
looking at my and it seems like magnus
hasn't
but maybe now he will so also in the
very first
game of this tournament the
preliminaries i also played my
chanceable course opening against him
and also won the games against damore
it was all from my chessable so it seems
they're not aware so i better take
advantage because
it could get outdated quickly
all right wesley well it's been a very
exciting day of chess i mean especially
that second game
was amazing but how disappointed were
you after that crazy opening
uh to make a blunder then i guess
yeah that was really unfortunate uh
really really really bad
because apparently i haven't analyzed
queen takes before move 21 because
obviously the engine gives me takes b5
that's the only move and then
it's point zero zero but uh the thing is
you only check what the engine gives and
so queen takes d4 is actually losing by
force
but the same time i didn't know how to
react and during the game i was
confused that's what was happening i
thought i mixed up already
some some move order because this
opening is is highly
complicated i mean white is not better
but it's just very unclear
and on move 18 queen city is actually
very important
uh because c5 is inaccurate because of
bishop c7 so there are some
move orders sublimities which uh could
be quite tricky so
i wasn't sure exactly i knew this was my
analysis but
i can't remember anything after queen
takes d4
and so i was hesitating whether i'm
still following my opening or whether
i'm already mixed up something but
yeah it's unfortunate because bishop c4
on move 22
should probably just win the game black
has
a piece in return for two pawns but his
problem is his minor pieces are very
badly
placed and all his beasts are are on in
bad positions and the knight is pinned
so yeah it's a waste of uh
good opening material but it happens
well and wesley after this loss
uh you played a draw but it was a
must-win situation for you then
in that last game and what sort of
mental exercises or or how did you get
yourself ready for that game
coming back so strong with that win you
really need it
well i just played my chess about cars
did you
yeah now in the last game i also played
the chessable course i had it on live
until
move 20. actually i just checked after
the game
on the course i the drug ab1 instead of
c4
but c4 looks very testing also because
black only has one way to equalize which
is not so easy to find and so um
so wesley i felt sorry sorry sorry karen
yes i felt like uh i should just stick
to my course because
um as what phoenix said if you if you
recommend something you should have the
courage to play it
but didn't expect this to work that well
and if some of the viewers
uh attempted to go and buy your
chesapeal course after seeing such
success against the world champion what
would you say to them what should they
expect from that course
yeah yeah well first thing for porting
well you can try it i mean you can
you have a 30-day money-back guarantee
that's a good thing about it
very good yeah you can always try it and
if it's crap you can return it but
but i i spent almost
a month or two working on this course so
the lines are very well researched
and also my course called lifetime
repair
so i try to make the lines very stable
and with a few updates it could very
well
last in their lifetime but um
yeah i'm happy that it worked so far in
this tournament
but at the same time to those viewers
who are just learning chess well
openings are just one thing i mean it's
good to have a stable opening repertoire
for for both callers
but at the same time you also need to be
good at other things such as the middle
game or tactics
well wesley then on day two you are tied
in the match should we expect you to
keep
bringing this opening or will you have
something other in store for us
yeah yeah yeah uh yeah it depends if
magnus is going to go skiing or if he's
going to look at my chest bulkheart
[Laughter]
very good well uh wesley we're so
excited for tomorrow hope you are as
well
good luck yeah thank you yeah thanks uh
hopefully i can put up a good fight
tomorrow
good luck wesley thanks for joining us
uh wesley so he is uh
tied with minus carlsen before the last
day
of the final it's going to be so intense
we're looking forward to that
and uh two great athletes these two
players
yeah and athletes that's the
theme for the quiz here's the theme we
did ask
which or which famous athlete would be
the best chess player and again the
answers came
thick and fast we were very impressed
and here are a few suggestions that we
liked
so we liked one suggestion from xbody gl
bodybuilding he says arnold
schwarzenegger and
franco colombo a total of nine mr
olympia titles could be the best
athletes
to be best chess players and we also
liked marion otetea who says cristiano
ronaldo would be the best
chess player because he is very
persuasive perseverant
and would take good lessons from magnus
carlsen when they meet
you can see there the two of the
champions together
i'm very envious of magnus's shirt
and we also liked barry rorshawn's
suggestion who said british formula one
driver
lewis hamilton would make a really
fantastic chess player master
strategist on the grid knows how to pull
out a win out of the bag
one 20 20 british grand prix with a
puncture on the last lap
wow and uh the winner of
our air things device is from kevin
room who says messi and ronaldo would be
great chess players
and need to play each other first to
find out who is the best
and there they are locked in
a battle of widths fantastic yeah i like
that
that one yeah great congratulations
kevin and someone will be in contact
asking for your details hope you enjoy
the air things device it's a wonderful
thing yeah
it is all right fantastic it's been fun
talking about football and sports
and chess all at the same time but david
tomorrow
two players in the finals well they have
to bring out their best
athletes and best chess players to win
for sure um we saw wesley so
in top form he looks in great physical
shape great mental shape
magnus carson we know he can do it
normally when the chips are down you
know in extra time he somehow brings his
a-game and i can't wait for tomorrow i
know we're having so much fun
in the studio working on this following
the best chess players in the world
and maybe you can join our team as well
because we're looking for some reporters
look at this
we are looking for tv reporters to join
our show
one in asia one in europe and one in
america
you will travel your continent doing
interviews with the players and will
join us
live to report from chess related events
do you
enjoy the thrill of being live on camera
can you
find the interesting stories and share
them with a global
audience send us some examples of your
work
and a screen test to tv casting at
playmagnets.com
yeah i would love it if we could just
have some live reporters in asia
in europe and in africa and or in the
americas
that we can actually go live to during
the show maybe they would be at like a
school chess tournament
or you know whatever sort of chess event
that would be amazing
that would be fantastic just to kind of
have the whole world connected globally
i mean i would
absolutely love it and i would love to
hear and hear this chess stories because
chess really connects everyone
it really does all right we are looking
for people to join or
our team tomorrow is the final day of
finals in the opera euro rapid this
tournament and i'm already getting
really excited we hope
you are as well it's gonna be a
fantastic day of chess with two of the
brightest brains in the world
wesley so and magnus carlsen so get
ready for the battle we hope you will
join us
as we follow the final tomorrow have a
good day or evening wherever you are in
the world
now and see you tomorrow bye
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
you